Hey guys, it's Joel and welcome to the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast, Part 7 of psychology on the couch, what American psychology can see, what it can't see, and why it struggles to tell the difference. So before I get into this episode, I'm going to put one idea in front of you that I'm going to keep coming back to it because I think it's the spine of what's kind of gone wrong with my profession, and we're creeping up to the end of, and a profession that, granted, can never be gotten 100% right and then be put in a box and be done. But one of the things that American institutions have had happen to them over the last 40 years, especially meaning-making, you know, human institutions, largely soft science institutions. Or maybe soft science is the wrong word, maybe institutions like education that it is incumbent on them to continue to evolve across their existence. And it's this. It's the way the profession defends a failed paradigm against its own data, because that's easier than change. And it's the way that, you know, a patient defends a failed self-image against their own felt experience or against the accountability of the real world when they have an internal world or an internal system of values and action and being that they think is more important than the results that's getting them in real life. And then can I have to take this moment where they say, okay, well, I thought this was the right way to do it, but the right way to do it keeps getting me burned.
大家好，我是Joel，欢迎收听Taproot Therapy Collective播客。这是“沙发上的心理学”系列的第七集，探讨美国心理学能看到什么，不能看到什么，以及为什么它难以区分这两者。在进入本集之前，我想先提出一个观点，我会反复提到它，因为我认为这是我的职业出现问题的核心所在。虽然一个职业永远不可能做到百分之百正确，然后就此定型，但过去40年来，美国机构——尤其是那些涉及意义构建的人文机构，或者说是软科学机构——发生了一些变化。也许“软科学”这个词不准确，或许像教育这样的机构，它们有责任在存在过程中不断进化。问题在于：这个行业为了捍卫一个失败的范式，不惜违背自己的数据，因为这比改变更容易。这就像一个病人为了捍卫一个失败的自我形象，不惜违背自己的真实感受，或者无视现实世界的问责，因为他们认为自己内心的一套价值观、行动和存在方式，比现实生活中得到的结果更重要。然后，他们不得不面对这样一个时刻：他们意识到，虽然自己认为这是正确的方法，但这种方法却总是让自己碰壁。
So maybe I need a better internal working model. You know, that's anyone who's been in therapy, you've felt that has. I feel that happen all the time when I'm like, but I should get these results from having this tactic because it's correct. And then it's not getting me the results. I got to change. That doesn't go away. Psychotherapy makes you better at that it doesn't fix it for you. It makes you aware and capable of guiding your own process or it should. So that micro of the individual doing that deflection on the inside being the same as the macro,
所以也许我需要一个更好的内部工作模型。任何做过心理治疗的人都感受过这一点。我经常有这种感觉，心想：“我用了这个策略，理应得到这些结果，因为它是正确的。”但结果却事与愿违。我必须改变。这种感觉不会消失。心理治疗让你更擅长处理这种情况，而不是为你解决问题。它让你意识到并有能力引导自己的过程，或者说它本应如此。所以，个体在内心进行这种防御的微观层面，与宏观层面是相同的，
or the large organization of hundreds of thousands of individuals sometimes. doing this on the outside is the same. And I want to build that bridge to explain why we're talking about the culture at the same time as the individual in therapy, at the same time as clinical practice of psychotherapy, you know, broadly across decades. So that macro tells the same lies that the micro tell. It has to.
或者说由成千上万个体组成的庞大组织在外部做同样的事情，本质是一样的。我想建立这座桥梁，来解释为什么我们在讨论心理治疗中的个体时，同时也在讨论文化，以及几十年来心理治疗的临床实践。宏观层面讲述着与微观层面相同的谎言。它不得不这样做。
They're just magnified. And it flatters the same biases the macro does that the micro has and vice versa. And we get sick. we get stuck in the same way. And so this episode is about how a profession that had spent $35 million to study whether its own treatment paradigm worked, got an answer back that it didn't like, and then proceeded for 20 years as if the study had never happened. And I want you to hear that as this clinical case study. Okay. Not as a story about science and infrastructure, although, and even though it is a story about the struggle of an institution, try and hear it like it's an
它们只是被放大了。宏观层面迎合了与微观层面相同的偏见，反之亦然。我们生病了，我们以同样的方式陷入困境。所以这一集是关于一个行业如何花费3500万美元来研究其自身的治疗范式是否有效，在得到一个它不喜欢的答案后，却在接下来的20年里表现得好像这项研究从未发生过一样。我希望你们把这当作一个临床案例研究来听。好的。不要把它仅仅看作一个关于科学和基础设施的故事，尽管它确实是一个关于机构挣扎的故事，但试着把它听作一个
individual that is struggling and deflecting from change on the psychotherapy couch. So in the late 90s, the National Institute of Mental Health funded the largest and most expensive antidepressant study in the history of American psych. The sequenced treatment alternatives to relieve depression study. Supposed to find the best thing to treat depression. And it's known to everyone in the field by star D or if you're typing it star astered D. So $35 million in federal money go into this thing. Forty thousand and 41 patients are enrolled. Huge study. 41 clinical sites. The most rigorous protocol the federal government could
在心理治疗沙发上挣扎并逃避改变的个体。在90年代末，美国国家心理健康研究所资助了美国心理学史上最大、最昂贵的抗抑郁研究——“缓解抑郁的序贯治疗替代方案研究”（STAR*D）。旨在找到治疗抑郁症的最佳方法。业内人士都称之为STAR*D。联邦政府为此投入了3500万美元。共有4041名患者参与。这是一项巨大的研究，涉及41个临床站点。这是联邦政府所能设计的
design. And the question that the study was built to answer was simple. In the real world with real patients, what percentages of depressed people actually get better when treated accordingly to current best practices? Evidence-based practice. So this is not a marginal study. Stardy is the study. You've got hundreds of other studies that cite it and point back to it. It's going to be very meta-analyzed. It's supposed to be something that everyone refers to for the next generation of research and it, it is. It didn't just waste the money that went into it them. It wasted the studies built around it because of that system, siding it, cleaning it up, meta-analizing it for the next two decades, apologizing for it, advertising its failures more broadly. It's designed to be this empirical foundation of,
最严谨的方案。这项研究旨在回答的问题很简单：在现实世界中，面对真实的患者，当按照当前的最佳实践（循证实践）进行治疗时，到底有多少比例的抑郁症患者真正好转了？所以这不是一项边缘研究。STAR*D就是“那项”研究。有数百项其他研究引用它并指向它。它将被反复进行荟萃分析。它本应成为下一代研究参考的基石，事实也确实如此。它不仅浪费了投入其中的资金，还因为整个系统的引用、美化、在接下来的二十年里对其进行荟萃分析、为其辩解、更广泛地宣传其失败，而浪费了围绕它建立的其他研究。它被设计为
the medication first treatment paradigm that had taken over American psychiatry in the 80s and 90s. And the paradigm said, if you want to see a psychiatrist, we're just going to tell you that you're going to get better. You're not going to be depressed. There's no problem. If you're willing to try on average, four or five any depressants and then do six to 12 sessions of CBT to clean up any of the weird behavioral things that you might be doing, that's all that anyone needs to be functioning psychologically well. And these things have a ton of nuance. This stuff. is examining medication precisely, but this is sort of the puzzle piece that it's fit into what it's built to find. I'm going to go through the whole study because it's very hard to turn these things into a compelling story.
80年代和90年代统治美国精神病学的“药物优先”治疗范式的实证基础。该范式宣称：如果你去看精神科医生，我们只会告诉你你会好起来的。你不会再抑郁了。没问题。只要你愿意尝试平均四到五种抗抑郁药，然后进行6到12次认知行为疗法（CBT）来清理你可能存在的任何奇怪的行为问题，这就是任何人心理健康运作所需的一切。这些事情有很多细微差别。这项研究正在精确地检验药物，但这只是它所嵌入的拼图的一部分，是它被建立来发现的东西。我将通读整个研究，因为要把这些东西变成一个引人入胜的故事非常困难。
But this is kind of what the study is supposed to be finding. And if you need more than that, then maybe you just have a personality disorder. You're not actually depressed or you're not really doing what you're saying you're doing. Or you're not motivated or something that the industry can blame you as this externality that's not a patient seeking treatment and getting better. Something that's not psychiatry or academic psychology's fault. It's your fault. And so everything depended on this study
但这基本上就是该研究应该发现的内容。如果你需要的不仅仅是这些，那么也许你只是有人格障碍。你并没有真正抑郁，或者你并没有真正按照我们说的那样去做。或者你缺乏动力，或者行业可以把你归咎为某种外部因素，而不是一个寻求治疗并好转的病人。这不是精神病学或学术心理学的错。是你的错。所以一切都取决于这项研究，
to put the nail in the head of this issue. And so the justification for 40 years of pharmaceutical research dollars is sort of supposed to be found by this thing. And the basis for clinical guidelines that determine what insurance companies would pay for, which they already are paying for them this way. So the study better find that that's right.
来给这个问题盖棺定论。因此，40年来制药研究资金的合理性，某种程度上应该由这项研究来证明。它也是临床指南的基础，决定了保险公司会为哪些治疗买单，而他们实际上已经按照这种方式在支付了。所以这项研究最好能证明这是正确的。
And for what physicians were trained to prescribe, which they already kind of were prescribing like this, which is why you could do a giant study across it. It already had been pre-considered best practice before, you know, being found by science. And science is iterative. You got to do smaller studies before bigger studies. And then you do the big one to put the last nail in the coffin. Like I get it.
以及医生被培训去开什么药，他们其实已经在这样开了，这就是为什么你可以进行一项跨度如此之大的研究。在被科学发现之前，它就已经被预先认为是最佳实践了。科学是迭代的。你必须在大型研究之前进行小型研究。然后你做那个大的来盖棺定论。我明白这一点。
But this is supposed to be the penultimate one. And so they were going to prove that this whole system that they'd been building that had kind of patchwork evidence. Or, you know, they were drawing a picture, making an assumption based on the smaller evidence, was going to be totally put. to bed. And the original results are published in 2006. And the headline is that cumulative remission rate of 67%. So two-thirds of patients after up to four sequential medications, as long as you're willing to try four, and then say, this doesn't work, and then get on another one, they achieved remission from depression. So close to 70%. And if you tried at least four medications, you know,
但这本应是倒数第二个。他们打算证明他们一直在建立的整个系统——虽然证据有些拼凑，或者说他们是在基于较小的证据进行假设和描绘——将彻底尘埃落定。最初的结果于2006年发表。标题是67%的累积缓解率。也就是说，在尝试多达四种序贯药物后，只要你愿意尝试四种，然后说“这个没用”，再换另一种，三分之二的患者实现了抑郁缓解。所以接近70%。如果你尝试了至少四种药物，你知道，
you called your psychiatrist, you said this one doesn't work, you tried another one. On average, you'd get remission from depression. So they want to say, you know, 67% about. You know, 70% of people are treatable by this system. And, you know, the other 30% will figure out, and that we'll flag them as treatment resistant and we'll do more science to figure out how to get to that. And so this is vindication because it's proof that the system can justify itself and that the treatment paradigm that we've really already been doing for about 10 to 15 years was correct. And so the number circulated immediately into clinical guidelines, textbooks, residency curriculum, you know, for psychiatrists, training, curricula for therapists, insurance authorization for
你给你的精神科医生打电话，说这个没用，你又试了另一种。平均来说，你会从抑郁中缓解。所以他们想说，大约67%。你知道，70%的人是可以被这个系统治愈的。而且，你知道，剩下的30%我们会想办法，我们会把他们标记为“难治性”，我们会做更多的科学研究来找出如何解决这个问题。所以这是一种辩护，因为它证明了该系统可以证明其自身的合理性，并且我们已经进行了大约10到15年的治疗范式是正确的。于是这个数字立即在临床指南、教科书、住院医师课程、精神科医生培训课程、治疗师培训课程、保险授权中流传开来，
criteria that you were supposed to tell a patient. No, no, no, that's not right. You have to go back and participate in this system, in this way, you know, turn off, because this is the science, that if you try four or five of these things, you're going to get better. And beyond that, it's kind of on work that you do or motivation that you're supposed to have, you know, some, you know, other kind of internal resilience. Or you've got another problem that we just haven't discovered yet, like a personality disorder or something that is the real reason why you're, you're not thinking that these things work. And so hundreds of, you know, hundreds of of thousands of people were denied other psych services, you know, or longer-term therapy,
以及你应该告诉病人的标准。不，不，不，那是不对的。你必须回去，以这种方式参与这个系统，你知道，关掉（质疑），因为这就是科学，如果你尝试四五种这些东西，你就会好起来。除此之外，这取决于你所做的努力或你应该具备的动力，你知道，某种其他的内在韧性。或者你有另一个我们还没发现的问题，比如人格障碍，或者其他什么东西，这才是你认为这些东西不起作用的真正原因。因此，成千上万的人因为这项研究而被拒绝提供其他心理服务，你知道，或者长期治疗，
or different kinds of therapy that were not evident space because of this study, and still are. And for a decade and a half, every American psychiatrist treating depression operated within a clinical universe organized around the assumption that the standard pharmacological approach worked for two-thirds of patients. And as somebody worked in the hospital for a part of this time, and then in clinical therapy for a lot of this time, you know, psychiatrists are doing the same thing that a lot of the good therapists that I talk about are doing. I mean, they'll just kind of tell you, yeah, this isn't right. You know, and that's why I titrate, I do these things, and I look for this flavor of a mood disorder,
或者因为这项研究，其他不属于“循证”的治疗方式被拒绝，现在依然如此。在长达十五年的时间里，每一位治疗抑郁症的美国精神科医生都在一个临床宇宙中运作，这个宇宙建立在“标准药物治疗方法对三分之二的患者有效”的假设之上。作为曾经在医院工作过一段时间，后来又长期从事临床治疗的人，你知道，精神科医生在做很多我谈到的优秀治疗师所做的事情。我的意思是，他们会直接告诉你，是的，这不对。你知道，这就是为什么我进行滴定，我做这些事情，我寻找这种情绪障碍的类型，
and they call this technically depression. I got to use the ICD code for, you know, depression. But, you know, here's what I think's going on. I mean, they always, these people were always actually doing the real science and the real, you know, loving, caring good work in the field to be healers. So it's not everybody, but this is, again, about incentive structures and system. This is a pretty big one. So everybody in the study had to follow the rules.
他们称这在技术上为抑郁症。我必须使用ICD代码来表示，你知道，抑郁症。但是，你知道，这是我认为正在发生的事情。我的意思是，他们总是，这些人实际上一直在做真正的科学，以及真正的，你知道，充满爱心、关怀、优秀的领域工作，成为治疗者。所以并不是每个人都这样，但这再次回到了激励结构和系统。这是一个相当大的问题。所以研究中的每个人都必须遵守规则。
You know, we made a system that was designed to basically dump evidence-based practice out when you hit the right buttons. And as long as you hit those buttons, then anything that it shot out, you were supposed to call evidence-based practice and assume that it was this reflection of reality that was right. When you had the right inputs, when you checked the right diagnostic, you know, boxes, when you made sure that these things went through an ethics commission, when you made sure that they were double-blinded so people didn't know what they were getting, when you made sure that which you know double blind come on you i've known multiple patients they were in a double blind research study for like ketamine or something and they were like
你知道，我们建立了一个系统，旨在当你按下正确的按钮时，基本上就会吐出“循证实践”。只要你按下了这些按钮，那么它吐出的任何东西，你都应该称之为“循证实践”，并假设它是反映现实的正确东西。当你有了正确的输入，当你勾选了正确的诊断框，当你确保这些东西通过了伦理委员会，当你确保它们是双盲的，这样人们就不知道他们得到了什么，当你确保——你知道双盲，得了吧，我认识好几个病人，他们参加了氯胺酮之类的双盲研究，他们说，
i got the placebo because i didn't trip after i ate the pill it was sawdust not ketamine i mean you can tell if you got ketamine or not um anyway that's an aside but and so because we had this you know machine um that this cold machine that we built that's supposed to say that everything that comes out is evidence-based practice as long as you obey the rules of what you input into it and it has to be treated as such. And if you don't do that, you're fringe and you're weird or, you know, what they usually tell you is like, oh, you just don't understand, but there's double-blind research, randomized controlled trials mean that even the researchers and the patients don't know who the, I know how it works, man. It's like, I wouldn't say the director
“我得到了安慰剂，因为我吃完药后没有产生幻觉，那是木屑，不是氯胺酮。”我的意思是，你能分辨出你是否得到了氯胺酮。嗯，不管怎样，这只是题外话。所以因为我们有这个，你知道，机器，我们制造的这台冷冰冰的机器，它应该说只要你遵守输入它的规则，出来的所有东西都是循证实践，并且必须被视为如此。如果你不这样做，你就是边缘的，你很奇怪，或者，你知道，他们通常会告诉你的是，哦，你只是不明白，但有双盲研究，随机对照试验意味着连研究人员和病人都不知道谁是……我知道它是怎么运作的，伙计。这就像，我不会说那位导演的名字，
because somebody will probably email me, but there's like a really big director who I like the way that he makes movies. And if you, I don't like the way that he makes movies, just because he's not making movies for me. That's fine. You can watch him. But if you say that, people will explain to you what he's doing. They're like, oh, but he's really obsessed with the 70s. And so it's like, tension is building for like a really long time. And like everything's like really small. Like it's a play.
因为有人可能会给我发邮件，但有一位我很喜欢他拍电影方式的非常大的导演。如果你，我不喜欢他拍电影的方式，只是因为他不是为我拍电影。没关系。你可以看他的电影。但如果你这么说，人们会向你解释他在做什么。他们会说，哦，但他真的很痴迷于70年代。所以就像，紧张感在很长一段时间内不断积累。而且一切都非常小。就像是一出戏。
And like the set is like and there's always a spotlight over somebody's head. And then like it gets really violent. And I'm like, I understand the period of, you know, cool that he's mining. I understand the vein. I understand why he makes movies. They're not why I watch movies. I'm not bad at understanding his influences. It's someone who like likes film.
而且布景是……而且总是有一个聚光灯照在某人头上。然后它变得非常暴力。我就想，我理解他正在挖掘的那个酷的时期。我理解那个脉络。我理解他为什么拍电影。它们不是我观看电影的原因。我并不是不理解他的影响。这就像一个喜欢电影的人。
I don't think that what he's doing. doing is good. And that's fine. You can. It's kind of like that. A lot of times when you voice these critiques, people will just start explaining to you, like how evidence-based practice works. Like, if you have more information about how complicated these machines are, you'll just fall into line. I know how they work. And they don't work well. You know, we know that these studies numbers were fiction because over the following years, you know, a small group of independent researchers working under what is called the restoring invisible and abandoned. trial initiative or riot they fought through the Freedom of Information Act to finally get the
我不认为他所做的是好的。这没关系。你可以（喜欢）。这有点像那样。很多时候，当你表达这些批评时，人们只会开始向你解释循证实践是如何运作的。就像，如果你有更多关于这些机器有多复杂的信息，你就会顺从了。我知道它们是如何运作的。而且它们运作得并不好。你知道，我们知道这些研究数字是虚构的，因为在接下来的几年里，你知道，一小群独立研究人员在所谓的“恢复不可见和被遗弃的试验倡议”（RIAT）下工作，他们通过《信息自由法》进行斗争，最终获得了
patient level data set which is something that really I mean I guess there's ways to release some of it without all of it and there's probably ethical concerns along this but really you should be able to get the anonymized data from any of these studies if we want to call it science because you should be able to read what did the clinician actually encounter in the room that they turned into a number for the study not just the number and that should be uh something that every study has to track and maintain. You should be able to pull that. It isn't generally something that we do. We just kind of act like, well, what do you need the thing that the person said and that was later interpreted into a number because we gave you the number? Well,
患者层面的数据集，这真的，我的意思是，我想有一些方法可以在不完全公开的情况下发布其中的一部分，而且这可能存在伦理问题，但实际上，如果我们想称之为科学，你应该能够从任何这些研究中获得匿名数据，因为你应该能够读到临床医生在房间里实际遇到了什么，他们将其转化为研究的数字，而不仅仅是那个数字，这应该是每项研究都必须跟踪和维护的东西。你应该能够提取它。这通常不是我们做的事情。我们只是表现得好像，好吧，为什么你需要那个人说的话，后来被解释为一个数字，因为我们给了你数字？好吧，
numbers are metaphors from distance. I want the data. And so, or the data is not the number, I would argue again. So, you know, this all should have been available anyway, but they have to fight. Pigeau is a really big one who does it. I mean, a lot of these people are very dedicated, they're funded, and they have kind of an axe to grind against this thing because they don't think it's right. And without them, we never would have known any of this information. And then it became this big scandal for the whole industry. But the original protocol specified that depression, but they were treated the whole time that they're trying to do this like they were just crazy people trolling the system. And so that depression severity, the original
数字是来自距离的隐喻。我想要数据。所以，或者说数据不是数字，我会再次争辩。所以，你知道，这一切本来都应该可以获得的，但他们必须去抗争。Pigeau是一个非常重要的人物，他做了这件事。我的意思是，这些人中的许多人都非常敬业，他们有资金，而且他们对这件事有一种不满，因为他们认为这不对。没有他们，我们永远不会知道任何这些信息。然后它成为了整个行业的一大丑闻。但最初的方案规定了抑郁症，但他们在试图做这件事的整个过程中，都被当作是在系统中捣乱的疯子。所以那种抑郁症的严重程度，最初的
protocol, what it said was that the way that you measured how severe a person's depression was to make sure that they were going into the study with depression and that they were coming out of the study without depression if it was working was called a Ham D. And this is a clinical administered blinded assessment that's been the standard for half a century. It's a good measure of depression. And so when the investigators ran their numbers using Ham D, which is what the study said it did, because that's a very good measurement engine. The remission, the remission, the remission, rates were not impressive. So they switched it halfway through the study. So mid-study, they realized they weren't getting the results they wanted. And again, this is not probably one person or a
协议中提到，衡量一个人抑郁程度的方法，即确保他们在进入研究时处于抑郁状态，而在研究结束后如果治疗有效则不再抑郁，这种方法被称为汉密尔顿抑郁量表（Ham-D）。这是一种临床管理的盲法评估，半个世纪以来一直是标准做法。它是衡量抑郁症的一种有效手段。因此，当研究人员使用Ham-D进行数据分析时（研究报告称其使用了该量表，因为这是一个非常好的测量引擎），缓解率并不令人印象深刻。于是，他们在研究进行到一半时更换了评估方法。也就是说，在研究中期，他们意识到没有得到想要的结果。同样，这可能不是某个人或某个阴谋集团在掩盖这些东西。
cabal covering this stuff up. It's just a system being like, well, we're hitting the right buttons and we're not getting the right results. So we got to go back and then you get the same process that happens in an individual that's deflecting, right? And I wasn't there. No one will ever probably know or cop to what happened in the study. But we find out later that mid-study, they said, oh wait, we're going to use the QIDS SR. And this is a self-reported questionnaire, totally different from a blinded study. So the patient fills it out unblinded, knowing what treatment they're receiving, if it was supposed to be the evidence-based practice, when or not.
这只是一个系统在说：好吧，我们按了正确的按钮，但没有得到预期的结果。所以我们必须回头，这和你个人在回避问题时发生的过程是一样的，对吧？我当时不在场，可能永远没人会知道或承认研究中发生了什么。但我们后来发现，在研究中期，他们说：哦等等，我们要改用QIDS-SR。这是一个自评问卷，与盲法研究完全不同。所以患者在非盲法的情况下填写，知道自己接受的是什么治疗，无论这是否被认为是循证实践。
And so the placebo effect is not controlled for the way that it would be in a blinded study. And then the self-reporting instruments produce systematically higher remission rates than blinded clinician-administered ones where the patient doesn't know. what they're marking on the assessment, basically. They're just answering honestly because they're not short of shooting for a target they think they're supposed to hit. And so because the person knows whether they were supposed to get better or not, that is going to influence how better they think they got. That doesn't necessarily mean that the self-reporting a placebo effect is going to hold up over a long period of time.
因此，安慰剂效应并没有像在盲法研究中那样得到控制。而且，自评工具产生的缓解率系统性地高于盲法临床医生评估的结果，因为在盲法评估中，患者不知道自己在评估表上标记了什么。他们只是诚实地回答，因为他们没有试图达到他们认为自己应该达到的目标。由于患者知道自己是否应该好转，这会影响他们认为自己好转的程度。这并不一定意味着自评的安慰剂效应能在很长一段时间内持续下去。
But it does mean that when you're doing this study that's short, they may end up showing you some data that is not right. And so the investigators also concluded in this publication that, you know, the remission count of 931 patients who, according to the protocol's own enrollment criteria, should never really have been in the study because they weren't depressed enough based on the hamd. 99 had this baseline depressive score that was too low to qualify. Like they were just saying that they had dysphoric periods, but it wasn't really treatment resistant depression that medication is supposed to be prescribed for. Or even significant depression. And so 508 had only mild depression, and they shouldn't have been in the study, because it wasn't when it was studying. And their depression not being severe is what they came in with.
但这确实意味着，当你进行这项短期研究时，他们最终可能会向你展示一些不准确的数据。因此，研究人员在发表的论文中也得出结论：根据协议本身的入组标准，931名患者本不应该参加这项研究，因为根据Ham-D量表，他们的抑郁程度不够严重。其中99人的基线抑郁评分太低，不符合资格。他们只是说自己有心境恶劣期，但这并不是药物应该治疗的难治性抑郁症，甚至算不上严重的抑郁症。因此，有508人只有轻度抑郁，他们本不应该参加研究，因为研究的对象并非如此。他们进入研究时，抑郁程度并不严重。
And 324 had no documented baseline severity score at all. So we don't really know what was going on with them. And then 124 patients were inappropriately included in the augmentation analysis, despite already being in remission from depression, that already received other treatment. So they maybe thought of themselves as depressed, responded to a study offering to, you know, compensate them or let them participate in this thing because it said, hey, are you depressed or do you have depression? And they'd been in treatment for it. But really, if you look at their clinical data, they've been cured of depression or they'd been in remission of depression for a while. So the study really shouldn't have let them end if it's doing a Hamdi at the beginning. And the numbers showed that.
此外，324人根本没有记录基线严重程度评分。所以我们真的不知道他们的情况如何。还有124名患者被不适当地纳入了增效分析，尽管他们已经从抑郁症中缓解，并接受过其他治疗。所以他们可能认为自己抑郁，响应了研究的号召，为了获得补偿或参与其中，因为研究问：嘿，你抑郁吗？或者你有抑郁症吗？他们之前一直在接受治疗。但实际上，如果你查看他们的临床数据，他们已经治愈了抑郁症，或者已经缓解了一段时间。所以如果研究在开始时使用Ham-D，就不应该让他们进入。数据也显示了这一点。
So they were already cured of the depression one way or another before they started. And so, of course, you know, it's still going to be gone by the end. of the study if they didn't have it when they started. Of course, it's going to be mild if they had mild depression when they started the study. And of course, if you have the people who are depressed who are being told and want to hope that they got, oh yeah, I got the right one. I didn't get the placebo. I got the real one that they got the real treatment. They're going to report more strongly that they got better. So when the riot team excluded the protocol violations, meaning if you did one of these things that was against what the study said its rules were, you
所以他们在开始之前就已经以某种方式治愈了抑郁症。因此，当然，如果他们在开始时就没有抑郁症，到研究结束时它自然会消失。如果他们在研究开始时只有轻度抑郁，当然结果会是轻度的。而且，如果那些抑郁的人被告知并希望自己得到了真正的治疗，而不是安慰剂，他们会更强烈地报告自己好转了。所以当Riot团队排除了违反协议的情况，也就是说，如果你做了违反研究规则的事情，你
removed everyone who broke the rules and you looked at the where they actually obeyed the rules for this remaining population of patients who actually got better was not close to 70 percent it wasn't 67 percent it was 2.7 percent so 108 patients who were willing to try four or five antidepressants CBT the normal treatment paradigm that's running the country largely still is running the country out of 4,000 and 41 people 108 got better two point. And that's the way that we have been training the machine and assuming that it worked. And even though this caused a whole lot of consternation and like new rules that academia would make up to make sure that its studies were evidence based, which we never really test if those rules actually make outcomes better. We just sort of do that based on vibes and then say they do.
移除了所有违规者，并观察那些真正遵守规则的人，剩余患者中真正好转的比例根本不是接近70%，也不是67%，而是2.7%。也就是说，在4041名愿意尝试四五种抗抑郁药、认知行为疗法（CBT）等目前在全国范围内仍占主导地位的常规治疗范式的患者中，只有108人好转了，即2.7%。这就是我们训练这套系统并假设它有效的方式。尽管这引起了极大的不安，并导致学术界制定了新规则以确保研究是循证的，但我们从未真正测试过这些规则是否真的改善了结果。我们只是根据感觉行事，然后声称它们有效。
But, you know, they said, hey, we'll change some things behind the scenes. And granted, they did. It's a lot easier now because I actually pulled these things to get the raw data from the studies, which is available. So if you're going to talk about a study at me on LinkedIn, you probably should have read that data because if you don't, you don't really know what's up. You're reading basically an op-ed by a researcher. And I get all of these people all the time. It's a lot easier to get this data after STARTD because one of the things that was good that they encouraged you to do is keep the actual. actual results that you were turning into the number, you know, with your assessment or your study, like the actual transcript of what the person says or a little bit closer to as much data as you could collect based on the type of study that you're doing.
但是，他们说：嘿，我们会在幕后做些改变。诚然，他们确实做了。现在容易多了，因为我实际上提取了这些研究的原始数据，这些数据是公开的。所以如果你要在LinkedIn上跟我谈论某项研究，你可能应该先读读那些数据，因为如果你不读，你就真的不知道发生了什么。你读的基本上是研究人员写的评论文章。我经常遇到这种情况。在STAR*D研究之后，获取这些数据容易多了，因为他们鼓励做的一件好事是保留你转化为数字的实际结果，也就是你评估或研究的实际记录，比如患者所说的实际转录，或者尽可能接近你根据研究类型所能收集到的数据。
And I have a ton of people where I just, I read the date of a study and I say like, hey, this thing isn't really measuring this because like it's pretending it like made this revolutionary point. But really, it's kind of making an obvious point that everyone knows. And the people are like, no, no, no, but the study says 70%. Or the study says 95%. I'm like, yeah, but what I'm saying is like read the transcript. It's stupid. Don't assume that you have read a research paper. You understand the research.
我有很多次阅读研究数据，然后说：嘿，这项研究并没有真正衡量这个，因为它假装得出了革命性的观点。但实际上，它只是提出了每个人都知道的显而易见的观点。而人们会说：不，不，不，但研究说70%或95%。我说：是的，但我说的是读读转录。这很愚蠢。不要以为你读了一篇研究论文就理解了这项研究。
This stuff's available. You can get it. If it's important to you, sometimes you have to jump through a couple hoops. If you have to jump through a lot of hoops, maybe wonder why they don't want you to have that information. But, you know, what it doesn't change is that these are rules that were proven wrong and proven not evidence-based. And they still run the world.
这些东西是公开的，你可以获取。如果这对你很重要，有时你必须克服一些障碍。如果你必须克服很多障碍，也许该想想为什么他们不想让你拥有这些信息。但是，这并不能改变一个事实，即这些规则已被证明是错误的，且并非基于证据。但它们仍然统治着世界。
They still run my world. The profession never said, oh, oops, we screwed up. It's shocking how a few therapists know about this, let alone patients are just normal Americans. You know, this wasn't on CNN. It wasn't on Fox News. This wasn't something that a lot of people even knew existed. And it shows you how little we care about American psych or how little it bleeds into the pop culture in the way that it used to. If you went back to the 70s, which there's some good things about that too.
它们仍然统治着我的世界。这个行业从未说过：哦，哎呀，我们搞砸了。令人震惊的是，很少有治疗师知道这一点，更不用说患者或普通美国人了。你知道，这并没有上CNN，也没有上福克斯新闻。这不是很多人甚至知道存在的事情。这表明我们对美国心理学有多么不在意，或者它在流行文化中的渗透程度远不如从前。如果你回到70年代，那时还有一些好的方面。
But it's just not really on the radar of the world because in any other profession, you know, if this was cardiology, right? You know, another thing that's probably kind of boring that most people don't want to just learn about until they have to because they have a heart problem. You know, but cardiology is a real hard science that is evidence-based. And the intervention, you know, it would be abandoned overnight. If you said if a hundred people go in for this heart surgery with real doctors and a real hospital with hundreds of thousands of dollars of medical billing per year per unit, oh, half get better, but the surgery's over. Oh, wait, no, it's not half. It's actually two percent of them.
但这在世界上根本不在雷达范围内，因为在任何其他行业，比如心脏病学，对吧？你知道，另一件可能有点枯燥的事情，大多数人除非不得不面对心脏问题，否则不想去了解。但是，心脏病学是一门真正的硬科学，是循证的。如果干预措施无效，它会一夜之间被废弃。如果你说，如果100个人在真正的医生和真正的医院里接受这种心脏手术，每年每单位花费数十万美元的医疗费用，哦，有一半人好转了，但手术结束了。哦，等等，不是一半，实际上只有2%的人好转了。
you know, if this were oncology, you know, the FDA would pull drugs and say, like, what the hell are you doing? You're giving somebody a cancer drug and only 98% of the people are getting worse or staying the same. Like the 2% that's just, you know, heads would roll. If this were any field where numbers were actually taken seriously, which is the thing that they want to say that they do, the numbers again, their metaphors from distance for the system's own blind spots, not forces of accountability, which if you wanted to build that system, I don't have a problem with numbers. You know, they were just using numbers to prove bullshit that they thought they'd already proved. And then they were still believing the bullshit when the numbers
你知道，如果是肿瘤学，FDA会撤回药物并说：你们到底在干什么？你给某人一种癌症药物，结果只有2%的人好转，而98%的人病情恶化或保持不变。那2%的人……你知道，这会引起轩然大波。如果这是任何一个真正认真对待数字的领域（这是他们声称自己所做的），那么这些数字再次成为了系统自身盲点的隐喻，而不是问责的力量。如果你想建立那个系统，我对数字没有意见。你知道，他们只是在用数字来证明他们认为已经证明的废话。然后当数字
didn't reflect that world back to them, which I'm sorry, that's the world you're in. And then that entire treatment apparatus would have to be rebuilt in any other profession. And Syke didn't even really seem to notice, which to me is a lot more nefarious than a cabal. It's a lot more nefarious than a, you know, a big, you know, Da Vinci Code conspiracy theory to run the world because it's just a system that means that the vast majority of clinicians are so dissociated from that the things they think they know, the things that they are taught, the things that they're holding up to are just like little factoids that deflect from the real body of knowledge that it is their job to understand. And it reminds me of the, uh,
没有反映出那个世界时，他们仍然相信那些废话。我很抱歉，这就是你所处的环境。在任何其他行业，整个治疗体系都必须重建。而心理学界似乎甚至没有注意到这一点，这对我来说比阴谋集团更邪恶。这比什么“达芬奇密码”式的统治世界的阴谋论更邪恶，因为它只是一个系统，意味着绝大多数临床医生与他们自认为知道的事情、他们被教导的事情、他们所坚持的事情如此脱节，这些只是为了掩盖他们本应理解的真正知识体系的小事实。这让我想起了……
the education system in Fahrenheit 451, which I haven't read since seventh grade. So like I'm probably getting some of this wrong. But in the education system in Fahrenheit 451, the kids spend all this time in school. But the school is basically fake knowledge that is real. So it's like trivia. It's things that are like trivia that you can memorize that make you feel like you've acquired knowledge. But they're not an understanding of how any sort of system works. So they're not threatening to any kind of system.
《华氏451》里的教育系统，我从七年级以后就没读过了，所以我可能记错了一些。但在《华氏451》的教育系统中，孩子们在学校里花了很多时间。但学校里教的基本上是虚假的知识，尽管看起来是真的。就像琐事一样。是一些你可以背诵的琐事，让你觉得你已经获得了知识。但它们并不是对任何系统如何运作的理解。所以它们对任何系统都没有威胁。
So they sit in the class and they're like, oh yeah, you know, President Bathtub, he was fat. And like this president, he did whatever. And they do all these things without really understanding the world that they're in. They're memorizing dates. They're memorizing names. They're memorizing basically history like it is a vocabulary test. You know, Abraham Lincoln is the person who did these things.
所以他们坐在教室里，就像：哦，是的，你知道，浴缸总统，他很胖。还有这位总统，他做了什么什么。他们做所有这些事情，却并不真正理解他们所处的世界。他们在背诵日期。他们在背诵名字。他们基本上像对待词汇测试一样背诵历史。你知道，亚伯拉罕·林肯就是做这些事情的人。
And that, there is some similarity here. So in American psychiatry, the original 67% figure is still cited sometimes. It can still pop up in people's like. LinkedIn, Infographics and PowerPoint researchers teaching kids in school. I see it on tons of different like, you know, welcome to social work, welcome to clinical psychology 101, you know, master's degree, slideshows. And not as embarrassing as it should be if it's still on things that you're teaching, even though, you know, maybe the professional researchers retracted a lot of it and had to print like,
这其中有一些相似之处。所以在美国精神病学中，最初的67%这个数字有时仍被引用。它仍然会出现在人们的LinkedIn、信息图表和PPT中，研究人员在学校里教给孩子们。我在无数不同的地方看到它，比如：欢迎来到社会工作，欢迎来到临床心理学101，你知道，硕士学位的幻灯片。如果这些东西还在教学中，这本应是令人尴尬的，尽管也许专业研究人员已经撤回了大部分内容，并不得不打印出……
you know, I'm sorry. They didn't have to give the money back. What if they had to give the money back? Maybe that people would be a little bit more careful if there was some personal accountability in this accountability creating system. You want to give us $44 million? So, you know, training programs still teach the medication algorithm that it was used to justify in the biomedical lens that was supposed to replace all the weird woo-woo stuff that psychotherapy didn't really need to bother itself with because it was too deep and too abstract. And just
你知道，我很抱歉。他们不必退钱。如果他们必须退钱会怎样？如果在这个问责创造系统中存在某种个人问责制，也许人们会更谨慎一些。你想给我们4400万美元吗？所以，你知道，培训项目仍然在教授药物算法，这些算法被用来证明生物医学视角的合理性，而这种视角本应取代所有那些心理治疗不需要费心处理的奇怪的“巫术”，因为它太深奥、太抽象了。而且仅仅
because you can see it doesn't mean that it's real. You know, the 15-minute med check that's still in your clinical encounter with the psychiatrist, why a CR&P, a lot of times, times, we'll get to spend more time with you, make a little bit more of informed thing, is because of the system. And it's because they can get to know exactly what's going on with you in 15 minutes. There's that assumption built into that. And a lot of people aren't even getting 15 from a psychiatrist, but that is what the billing code says. And that assumption that is enough is still with us. And the infrastructure has continued to operate as if the 67% figure is real, because the alternative is acknowledging that the dominant paradigm doesn't work for 97%
因为你能看到它，并不意味着它是真实的。你知道，仍然存在于你与精神科医生临床接触中的15分钟药物检查，为什么CRNP（注册护士执业者）通常会花更多时间陪你，做出更明智的判断，是因为这个系统。这是因为他们可以在15分钟内准确了解你的情况。这其中内置了那种假设。很多人甚至从精神科医生那里得不到15分钟，但账单代码上就是这么写的。那种认为这已经足够的假设仍然伴随着我们。基础设施继续运作，就好像67%的数字是真实的一样，因为另一种选择是承认主流范式对97%
of patients receiving it. And that would mean that would have to go back and dismantle the apparatus, which is something that American psychology, the cold machine of it, cannot do. And the apparatus has become independent of the truth, conditions that originally justified it that we all assumed would just fall in line later. We've been making those for 40 years, and nothing has ever fell behind the assumption that we're making to actively justify that we picked the right direction. And the wall's own data destroyed the wall's own case. And the wall just kept standing, and we kept
的患者无效。这意味着必须回头拆除这个装置，这是美国心理学这个冷酷的机器无法做到的。这个装置已经变得独立于真理，独立于最初证明其合理性的条件，我们都假设这些条件以后会自然对齐。我们已经为此努力了40年，没有任何东西能落后于我们为了积极证明我们选择了正确方向而做出的假设。墙壁本身的数据摧毁了墙壁本身的案例。而墙壁依然屹立，我们一直在
moving goalposts. So feel the parallel of the micro and the macro of the patient and the system being afraid of the worm ghost and clinging to the cold machine that is the right way to do it, the rules, the objective proof, the objective proof, the objective, reality, the system that is supposed to bring accountability, that everyone else in reality is just not obeying the way that they should if they knew the rules better, the rules that I know, not the thing that I feel, the self-evident truth, that the story is telling us.
移动球门。所以感受一下患者与系统的微观和宏观的平行，害怕“蠕虫幽灵”，并紧紧抓住那台冷酷的机器，认为那是正确的方法，规则，客观证明，客观证明，客观现实，那个本应带来问责的系统，每个人在现实中只是没有按照他们如果更了解规则就应该遵守的方式去遵守，那些我知道的规则，而不是我感觉到的东西，那个不言自明的真理，故事告诉我们的。
You know, the same way that people will make this case in life, that there are, you know, punishments and rewards if you obey the system. Well, that's not true. In life, there are just consequences of your actions. And understanding the system is going to be part of that, even bad ones. But the moral imperative of this is the way that it works. And if you conform to it, you're doing better, is a belief in the system over the real. And so listen to that in this story.
你知道，就像人们在生活中会提出这种观点一样，如果你遵守系统，就会有惩罚和奖励。嗯，那不是真的。在生活中，只有你行为的后果。理解系统将是其中的一部分，即使是糟糕的系统。但这种道德上的必要性，即这就是它的运作方式，如果你顺从它，你就会做得更好，这是一种对系统的信仰，胜过了对现实的信仰。所以在这个故事中听听这一点。
You know, when a patient comes into the room and you find evidence that they can't afford to integrate, evidence that their family of origin was doing something harmful when they needed to remember the family as loving. or and their own story is good, not a sad one. Or evidence that their work is killing them or the mask that they have to wear to do that work or the system that requires their work to extract something from them, even though their identity is built on that. And they need to view it as something that is not damaging because they get a reward from it, you know, usually egoic or financial.
你知道，当病人走进诊室，你发现证据表明他们无法承受整合，或者证据表明当他们需要将原生家庭视为充满爱意时，原生家庭却在伤害他们，而他们自己的故事其实很美好，并非悲剧。又或者证据表明他们的工作正在摧毁他们，或者为了工作他们必须戴上某种面具，又或者这个系统要求他们的工作从他们身上榨取价值，尽管他们的身份认同是建立在这些工作之上的。他们需要将这一切视为无害，因为他们从中获得了回报，你知道，通常是自尊心或经济上的回报。
Or evidence that the relationship that they're in is unsafe because their nervous system is telling them that, that this person is maybe pretending to be loving, but really, behind the scenes, they're setting this person up to fail, knowingly or unknowingly. That's happening in a relationship. But they need to view the last 20 years with this person as being safe. Nothing really needs to change. The problem's all me, you know.
又或者证据表明他们所处的恋爱关系是不安全的，因为他们的神经系统在发出警告，对方可能是在假装深情，但实际上在背后，对方正有意或无意地诱导他们走向失败。这种事正在关系中发生。但他们需要将与此人共度的过去20年视为安全的。觉得什么都不需要改变，问题全在自己身上，你知道的。
You watch something specific happen when you stumble on evidence that's going to contradict a patient center narrative. You know, they acknowledge the evidence, and then they file it, and then they continue, and then the next session, it's gone. The next session, it never happened. Six months later, they bring up the same problem in a different costume, but they want to make sure that they phrase it differently so that you can't link it to the thing
当你偶然发现与病人核心叙事相矛盾的证据时，你会观察到某种特定的反应。你知道，他们承认了这些证据，然后将其归档，接着继续谈话，到了下一次咨询时，这些证据就消失了。下一次咨询时，仿佛从未发生过。六个月后，他们换了个包装又提出了同样的问题，但他们会确保措辞有所不同，这样你就无法将其与那件
that they don't want to see. And it's the job of a talented therapist to be able to acknowledge and overcome that in a way that I would argue maybe can't be taught or can't be taught through just direct if there's some that type of education that is trivia. And so, you know, the federal government brought the field, you know, a $35 million mirror and the mirror reflected back a face that the field could not afford to see. They could talk about how the study had this problem, and so they're going to make changes,
他们不想面对的事情联系起来。而一位优秀的治疗师的工作，就是能够识别并克服这一点，我认为这可能无法通过教学来实现，或者说无法通过直接的教育来实现，如果那种教育只是琐碎的知识。所以，你知道，联邦政府给这个领域带来了一面价值3500万美元的镜子，而镜子映照出了一张这个领域无法面对的脸。他们可以谈论这项研究存在什么问题，所以他们会做出改变，
but they couldn't really say we did something wrong because the system doesn't work. The field acknowledged the reflection in academic venues, and the field filed this reflection. It was so important that we sit and think about stuff, that it's deep so that we don't have to change. And then the field continued. And the next year, the reflection was gone.
但他们无法真正说出“我们做错了”，因为这个系统本身就不行。该领域在学术场合承认了镜中的影像，然后将这个影像归档了。他们认为坐下来思考这些事情非常重要，显得很深刻，这样我们就不必做出改变。然后该领域继续前行。第二年，那个影像就消失了。
The next year, it never happened. 20 years later, the same problem is back in different costumes, and the apparatus looks at it with no recognition that this is the same system. Same thing that happened with the DSM, 4, 5, and 6, is going to happen with 6, I believe. And that is the same defense that this patient runs at the personal scale, run by an entire profession at the institutional scale. Same mechanism, same payoff, same cost. I'm going to keep showing you this parallel throughout the rest of this episode and series, because once you see it, if you want to, to see it, you can't unsee it. And this episode is about what happens to a profession when it's empirically established foundation collapses underneath it. And the profession refuses to notice,
第二年，仿佛从未发生过。20年后，同样的问题换了包装又回来了，而这个机构在审视它时，完全没有意识到这就是同一个系统。我相信，DSM-4、5和6发生的事情，也会在6（译注：此处原文疑为口误，应指后续版本）身上重演。这就是该病人个人层面所采取的防御机制，被整个行业在机构层面所执行。同样的机制，同样的代价，同样的后果。在接下来的剧集和系列中，我会不断向你展示这种平行关系，因为一旦你看到了，如果你愿意去看的话，你就再也无法假装没看见。这一集讲的是，当一个行业的经验性基础在它脚下崩塌时，会发生什么。而这个行业拒绝察觉，
which is scarier than an act of conspiracy theory or a lie or a cabal. It's a dissociative element of faith in a system that you don't understand, you can't understand, but you have to participate in it, but you can't feel it while you participate in it, so you become blind. Because if you saw it, would make your mind rebel. So you've got to just not see the thing that you are feeling all the time. You've got to not understand the implications of what you're doing. It's about the replication crisis, the biomarkers that never arrived, the moment in 2013 when the NIMH director said the Stardee criteria of the field were wrong. But once you understand what Stardy actually showed, and once you understand that nothing changed in response to that, even though there was a whole lot
这比阴谋论、谎言或秘密集团的行为更可怕。这是一种对某种你并不理解、也无法理解的系统的信仰所产生的解离元素，但你必须参与其中，而在参与时你又无法感知它，于是你变得盲目。因为如果你看到了，你的心智会反抗。所以你必须对你时刻感受到的东西视而不见。你必须不去理解你所做之事的含义。这关乎重复性危机，关乎从未实现的生物标志物，关乎2013年NIMH（美国国家心理健康研究所）主任说该领域的Stardee标准是错误的那一刻。但一旦你理解了Stardy实际上展示了什么，一旦你理解了尽管进行了大量的
of talking, which the field is very good at, and a whole lot of more rules. It's really good at coming up with new rules. You understand that we're not only dealing with science, we're dealing with infrastructure. And the infrastructure only responds to its own logic, not to evidence, but it will dress its own logic up as evidence or expect you to treat it as such. And the mystery and the certainty that used to guide the profession, the ability to sit with the uncertainty, the ability to know that there were things that were not, that were present, but not necessarily measurable.
讨论——这是该领域非常擅长的——以及制定了更多的规则，却没有任何改变。它非常擅长制定新规则。你就会明白，我们处理的不仅仅是科学，我们处理的是基础设施。而基础设施只响应它自己的逻辑，而不是证据，但它会把自己的逻辑包装成证据，或者期望你将其视为证据。而曾经引导这个行业的神秘感和确定性，那种与不确定性共处的能力，那种知道有些事物虽然存在但不一定能被量化的能力，
I think those are inseparable parts of what we lost. And I think perennially they will continue to pop up to remind us that they're inseparable, but we have to be able to see them. One of the more damning parts of Star D was it was supposed to investigate what happens when you were suicidally depressed. And you go to a psychiatrist and the medication that you got put on doesn't work. What are your other options? And so looking under the hood wasn't really supposed to be what they found. You're not really supposed to do any kind of depth work or you're,
我认为这些是我们失去的部分中不可分割的一部分。我认为它们会不断地浮现出来，提醒我们它们是不可分割的，但我们必须能够看到它们。Star D最令人诟病的部分之一是，它本应调查当你处于自杀性抑郁状态时会发生什么。你去看精神科医生，而你服用的药物不起作用。你还有什么选择？所以，深入探究并不是他们真正想要发现的东西。你本不应该做任何深度的心理工作，或者你，
realign knowledge of yourself, your life, your expectations of life, or accept phases of life, or things like that. Any kind of semantic, even, work. Not even, you know, CBT is needed. Any kind of looking at the culture you're in or how it's affecting you or the way you're making meaning. Those things are not looked at. This was trying to find a solution to suicidality without those things. And so the study didn't really want to find what it found, but it wanted to find that there was this option for you without doing any of those things. And that's what it was designed to do. And the standard clinical practice was to add a second medication. So Stardee had this specific arm to track those patients that had failed the first time and were still suicidally depressed called
重新认识你自己、你的生活、你对生活的期望，或者接受生活的阶段，诸如此类的事情。甚至任何语义上的工作。甚至不需要CBT（认知行为疗法）。任何对你所处的文化、它如何影响你，或者你赋予意义的方式的审视。这些都没有被审视。这试图在没有这些东西的情况下找到解决自杀倾向的方法。所以这项研究并不真的想发现它所发现的东西，它想发现的是，在不做任何这些事情的情况下，你还有这个选择。这就是它的设计初衷。而标准的临床实践是增加第二种药物。所以Stardee有一个特定的分支来追踪那些第一次失败且仍然处于自杀性抑郁状态的病人，称为
step two. That compared those two different augmentation strategies. Is it better to give people bupropion or busparone? And you know, Buespar or wellbutrin. And they published results that said that the two strategies were roughly equivalent in efficacy, and both were modestly helpful. Both were reasonable choices. Clinician could use whichever one they wanted, and that that was evidence-based. And just to opine for a second here, you know, the setup of Stardy is that you start with cetallopram, right, which is this antidepressant, and then if you fail on that one, you move to busperone, you know, Bustpar or Wellbutrin.
第二步。它比较了那两种不同的增强策略。给人们服用安非他酮（bupropion）还是丁螺环酮（buspirone）更好？你知道，Buspar或Wellbutrin。他们发表的结果称，这两种策略在疗效上大致相当，而且都有适度的帮助。两者都是合理的选择。临床医生可以使用他们想要的任何一种，而且那是基于证据的。在这里多说一句，你知道，Stardy的设置是你从西酞普兰（citalopram）开始，对吧，这是一种抗抑郁药，然后如果你失败了，你就换成丁螺环酮，你知道，Buspar或Wellbutrin。
And Welbutin's an antidepressant, Busebron's in anti-anity, and to find them equally, just to say that they're both equally effective, it's kind of funny because what I've said for a long time is that depression and anxiety are, you know, should be more seen as the spectrum diagnosis where you wiggle back and forth. That's kind of if you look at this data, which we'll get into later, but if you look at it as just data, diagnoses probably should work that way, but we're still stuck using these diagnoses that we can't change because they're so old. And so then we have to try and make the data fit them. But I mean, just saying, hey, when someone's super depressed, you can treat them with an antidepressant or you can treat them with an anti- anxiety medication and it does the same thing for depression. Well, it's kind of telling you that anxiety is a component of depression and vice versa, that it's this sort of you're counterbalancing and energy, but we don't want to look at these things that way. So anyway, so if you fail at SatylauPram and step one of Stardy and step two, you get put on either BUSBarr or Welbutrin and they say both of these are the same. They're both reasonable choices. There's not really one that the evidence prefers over the other. But when the riot team got the underlying data and they broke it out by
Wellbutrin是一种抗抑郁药，Buspar是一种抗焦虑药，仅仅因为它们效果相当就说它们同样有效，这有点滑稽，因为我长期以来一直说，抑郁和焦虑应该被视为一种谱系诊断，你在其中摇摆不定。如果你看这些数据，我们稍后会深入探讨，但如果你只把它看作数据，诊断可能应该那样运作，但我们仍然被困在使用这些无法改变的诊断中，因为它们太老了。所以我们必须尝试让数据去适应它们。但我的意思是，仅仅说，嘿，当某人极度抑郁时，你可以用抗抑郁药治疗他们，或者你可以用抗焦虑药治疗他们，这对抑郁症的作用是一样的。好吧，这其实是在告诉你，焦虑是抑郁的一个组成部分，反之亦然，这是一种能量的平衡，但我们不想那样看待这些事情。所以，总之，如果你在Stardy的第一步中西酞普兰治疗失败，在第二步中，你会被换成Buspar或Wellbutrin，他们说这两者是一样的。它们都是合理的选择。并没有证据表明哪一个比另一个更好。但是，当Riot团队拿到原始数据并按
treatment emergent suicidal ideation, the new emergence of suicidal thoughts and patients who had not had them at the start of treatment. Yeah, Stardy wasn't controlling for that. So these are patients who went in, they said they were, but they weren't. So these are patients who went in to the study, got put on a drug, got put on another drug, and now they're suicidal. But suicidality was not the thing that they came in with. So they got worse, much worse, because they started off, you know, depressed enough to qualify for the study, supposedly. And they're ending, on their third medication, suicidal. So that wasn't what they went to psychiatry for.
治疗中出现的自杀意念进行分类时，即在治疗开始时没有自杀念头的患者中新出现的自杀想法。是的，Stardy没有控制这一点。所以这些病人进去时，他们说他们是（抑郁），但他们没有（自杀念头）。所以这些病人进入研究，服用了一种药，又服用了另一种药，现在他们有了自杀倾向。但自杀倾向并不是他们最初就有的问题。所以他们变得更糟了，糟糕得多，因为他们开始时，你知道，抑郁程度足以符合研究资格，据称。而他们结束时，在服用第三种药物时，有了自杀倾向。那不是他们去看精神科的原因。
The medication had made them suicidal. And I mean, I'm inferring maybe some of them would have become suicidal anyway, but the rate in Buesprone argumentation, like that arm 13.9%, almost one in seven patients who started on Buseparone began having suicidal thoughts that they had not had before. In the Bupropion arm, the Lelbutrin arm,
药物使他们产生了自杀倾向。我的意思是，我推测也许其中一些人无论如何都会产生自杀倾向，但丁螺环酮增强组的比率，那个分支是13.9%，几乎七分之一开始服用丁螺环酮的病人开始产生他们以前没有过的自杀想法。在安非他酮组，即Wellbutrin组，
the rate was 3.6%. So roughly four times less. So it seems, seems like, well, Butrin is a better option than BUSBAR for suicidal depression. You know, this is clinically an enormous difference. If you're an honest psychiatrist trying to choose between those two argumentation strategies, but if you're an honest psychiatrist looking at the data and you don't have access to everything that the riot team basically had to subpoena, then you don't know any of this stuff.
比率是3.6%。所以大约低了四倍。所以看起来，Wellbutrin似乎是治疗自杀性抑郁症比Buspar更好的选择。你知道，这在临床上是一个巨大的差异。如果你是一位诚实的精神科医生，试图在两种增强策略之间做出选择，但如果你是一位诚实的精神科医生，看着数据，而你无法获得Riot团队基本上不得不通过传票才能获得的所有信息，那么你就不知道这些东西。
And, you know, the suicidality difference is exactly the kind of information that you need to know. And it's the difference between a medication that might help and a medication that might kill the patient. And maybe they do have an anxious depression. And the same drug is fine. If you have good data and you can say, hey, look, this is an option. We're going to try this. This is a potential side effect. We're going to put you on this plan.
而且，你知道，自杀倾向的差异正是你需要知道的那种信息。这关乎一种可能有所帮助的药物和一种可能杀死病人的药物之间的区别。也许他们确实有焦虑性抑郁症。同样的药物也没问题。如果你有好的数据，你可以说，嘿，看，这是一个选择。我们要尝试这个。这是一个潜在的副作用。我们要把你纳入这个计划。
And if you become suicidal, you've got to page our clinic immediately. You know, I did that at the hospital a lot when we were making a change that we thought was probably good, but may have a temporary or lasting adverse side effect that we needed to be aware of. And the investigators had all this data and they did not publish it. They hit it from themselves bureaucratically. I don't think they put it under the rug because they were embarrassed. I think they could not see it because they were part of this machine.
如果你产生了自杀倾向，你必须立即呼叫我们的诊所。你知道，我在医院时经常这样做，当我们做出我们认为可能很好，但可能具有我们需要注意的暂时性或持久性不良副作用的改变时。而研究人员拥有所有这些数据，但他们没有发表。他们在官僚层面上对自己隐瞒了这些数据。我不认为他们把这些数据扫地出门是因为他们感到尴尬。我认为他们看不见这些数据，因为他们是这台机器的一部分。
And they covered it up because it wasn't what they were looking for. They knew what the study was, quote unquote, supposed to find before they did the study. So when it didn't show them that, they could not see it. And that's how we do research still. And again, I'm not saying antipsychotic medication makes you worse. Don't take antidepressants. There is a need for these things. They work.
他们掩盖了它，因为它不是他们正在寻找的东西。他们在做研究之前就知道这项研究“应该”发现什么。所以当它没有向他们展示这一点时，他们就看不见它。这就是我们至今仍在做研究的方式。再说一次，我不是说抗精神病药物会让你变得更糟。不要服用抗抑郁药。这些东西是有需求的。它们有效。
I see them work all the time. I've been on them myself. I've been suicidal before. I've been on wobutrin. It was effective. And I've watched that happen in patients. It's just that it's not a 100% this works for everything. We've solved mental health and we're moving forward thing.
我一直看到它们有效。我自己也服用过。我以前也有过自杀倾向。我服用过Wellbutrin。它很有效。我看到病人们身上也发生了同样的情况。只是它并不是“这百分之百对所有事情都有效，我们已经解决了心理健康问题，我们正在前进”的那种东西。
There are things that need to be understood by clinicians who need that information. And so I'm not telling you don't take your medication. I'm not telling you don't go to therapy. Absolutely do not take that away from what I'm saying. I'm critiquing the way that we could have understood what would help people better with more nuanced. You know, granted, these drugs help a lot of people. That's why we were doing the studies. We wanted to find out how much people they helped and when and
有些事情需要临床医生去理解，他们需要那些信息。所以我不是在告诉你不要吃药。我不是在告诉你不要去接受治疗。绝对不要从我的话中得出那种结论。我是在批评我们本可以以更细致的方式去理解什么能更好地帮助人们。你知道，诚然，这些药物帮助了很多人。这就是我们进行研究的原因。我们想找出它们帮助了多少人，在什么时候，以及
and what kind of people. And clinically, though, that enormous difference, psychiatrists were all told and was just the same. And if you said, hey, I don't think this is the same. It doesn't feel the same to me. I don't feel, well, that's not what the evidence says, is what a lot of people got told, you know, psychiatrists and patients, you know, residents, psychiatrists and patients. And the riot team also examined records for severe suicidal behaviors, the medical category for actual suicide attempts, people who are starting to do things, not think about doing things, starting to make plans that will lead to their death, their own death, consciously. You know, walking up to the edge of a building, cutting themselves deeper and deeper, dark things, and the treating clinicians at the study sites had documented 16 such events across the trial,
以及什么样的人。但在临床上，那个巨大的差异，精神科医生都被告知这只是“一样的”。如果你说，嘿，我不认为这是一样的。对我来说感觉不一样。我不觉得……好吧，很多人被告知“证据不是这么说的”，你知道，精神科医生和病人，你知道，住院医生、精神科医生和病人。Riot团队还检查了严重自杀行为的记录，这是实际自杀企图的医学类别，人们开始做一些事情，而不是考虑做一些事情，开始制定会导致他们死亡的计划，他们自己的死亡，有意识地。你知道，走到建筑物边缘，割伤自己越来越深，黑暗的事情，而研究地点的治疗临床医生在整个试验中记录了16起此类事件，
the official serious adverse events report, and the document that gets submitted to regulators informs the basis of the published safety record, listed only four. and 12 actual suicide attempts documented by clinicians who saw the patients were never reported. And look, these are the best researchers in the world, the ones with the most laurels, the most money, the most you won the system of doing evidence-based practice, and this is what the system produced. And I don't think there's one guy in a room saying, like, oh, crap, we found this and we're not, you know, going to cover it up. And I don't even think, like, a lot of critiques of this study, because one of the reasons they started changing things was a placebo or what they thought was a placebo. I think it was like St. John's word or a mugwort or something. It was like an herbal supplement.
官方的严重不良事件报告，以及提交给监管机构并构成已发表安全记录基础的文件，只列出了四起。而临床医生记录的12起实际自杀企图从未被报告。看，这些是世界上最好的研究人员，拥有最多荣誉、最多资金、最赢得了循证实践体系的人，而这就是该系统产生的结果。我不认为有一个人在房间里说，哦，糟糕，我们发现了这个，我们不打算掩盖它。我甚至不认为，像很多对这项研究的批评那样，因为他们开始改变事情的原因之一是安慰剂，或者他们认为是安慰剂的东西。我想那是什么圣约翰草或艾蒿之类的东西。那是一种草药补充剂。
They were finding that it was working better than the well butrin in some of the cases. And so that was one of the reasons for one of the multiple reasons why this study, they started changing their own measurement of depression and effectiveness. I mean, to me, it would be less scary if we found out that like Pfizer had taken all the best researchers in the world and then paid them off and been like, oh, I want you to change data and here's a million dollars. What's more scary than that, which I think you could, is what happened was that you have basically a dissociated class that can't see what's in front
他们发现它在某些情况下比Wellbutrin更有效。所以这是这项研究中，他们开始改变自己对抑郁症和有效性的衡量标准的多个原因之一。我的意思是，对我来说，如果我们发现像辉瑞公司那样把世界上最好的研究人员召集起来，然后收买他们，说，哦，我想让你修改数据，这里有一百万美元，这反而没那么可怕。比那更可怕的是，我认为你可以（预见），发生的事情是，你基本上有一个解离的阶层，他们再也看不见眼前的东西了，
of it anymore because they're so tied to the way things are supposed to work. And the way that things are supposed to work has been divorced from how they actually do. It's willful blindness because we can't possibly admit how complicated systems are. We have to reduce them down to, you know, something that we can measure. And this is one of the bigger studies we're even able to do. And if we can't reduce them, then we'll reduce them down into something. And we'll just keep the direction going that we're going in. And eventually somebody else will find evidence that the direction that we decided to go in,
因为他们太受限于事情“应该”运作的方式。而事情“应该”运作的方式已经与它们实际运作的方式脱节了。这是故意的盲目，因为我们不可能承认系统是多么复杂。我们必须把它们简化为，你知道，我们可以测量的东西。而这是我们甚至能够做的更大的研究之一。如果我们不能简化它们，那么我们就会把它们简化成某种东西。然后我们将继续沿着我们正在走的道路走下去。最终其他人会找到证据，证明我们决定走的道路，
which usually is the easiest one for the current establishment to go in, is right. Well, this is coming up on the 60th year of when I first started about us doing these. And that hasn't happened. We don't have any data that this is the right direction, that these diagnoses mean anything other than we know what they're called and we like them and we wrote our books about them. And I mean, they're better than nothing. Well, like I said, anxiety and depression.
这通常是当前体制最容易走的道路，是正确的。好吧，这快到我第一次开始谈论我们做这些事情的第60个年头了。而那并没有发生。我们没有任何数据表明这是正确的方向，这些诊断除了我们知道它们叫什么，我们喜欢它们，我们为它们写了书之外，没有任何意义。我的意思是，它们总比没有好。好吧，就像我说的，焦虑和抑郁。
I mean, this is probably a spectrum or, you know, some sort of spectral diagnosis. Maybe there's multiple points on the star. It's not just a left-right spectrum. But these things do not operate the way that we pretend they do. And to me, fraud is less scary than the bureaucratic incentive doing this. I mean, I think fraud is. way less prevalent and way less of a problem. And after working in the places that I've worked, then the bureaucratic incentive. And I don't think that Starr D investigators sat in a room
我的意思是，这可能是一个谱系，或者，你知道，某种光谱诊断。也许星星上有多个点。它不仅仅是一个左右谱系。但这些东西的运作方式并不像我们假装的那样。对我来说，欺诈比官僚激励机制做这种事更不可怕。我的意思是，我认为欺诈比官僚激励机制要普遍得多，问题也小得多。在我工作过的地方工作之后，我不认为Stardee的研究人员坐在一个房间里
and tried to cover up a suicide attempt. I think it was a structurally disturbing event that the structure had to control for and did. And for investigators who were operating inside of an apparatus whose continued funding, whose institutional reputation, whose entire reason to be, depended on demonstrating that medication first paradigm worked and that the very minimal time limited therapy protocol to the extent that it was needed at all was just part of that. I think they believed the thing that was the easiest for them to believe. For the system to operate on. And they believed it so strongly that they could not see reality that was outside of the apparatus.
并试图掩盖一起自杀企图。我认为这是一个结构上令人不安的事件，结构必须对其进行控制，而且确实做到了。对于那些在机构内部运作的研究人员来说，他们的持续资金、机构声誉、存在的全部理由，都依赖于证明“药物优先”范式有效，以及那种极度有限的、有时限的治疗方案（在它确实需要的情况下）只是其中的一部分。我认为他们相信了对他们来说最容易相信的事情。为了让系统运作。他们相信得如此坚定，以至于他们看不见机构之外的现实。
And this is what apparatus capture looks like. It's what the trap of the cold machine does. You can see the machine. You lose the worm ghost. And that's why I spent in episode four talking about Thomas, pension in the paranoid style. That's why I spent time talking about IBM punch cards. The infrastructure simply absorbs the criticisms. It co-ops them. And it issues a measured response like we did to the Stard E study. I'm sorry, we'll do evidence-based practice harder.
这就是机构捕获的样子。这就是冷酷机器的陷阱。你可以看到机器。你失去了蠕虫幽灵（译注：此处可能指代某种核心灵魂或本质）。这就是为什么我在第四集花时间谈论托马斯·品钦的偏执风格。这就是为什么我花时间谈论IBM打孔卡。基础设施只是吸收了批评。它收编了它们。并发布了一个像我们对Stardee研究那样适度的回应。对不起，我们会更努力地进行循证实践。
And it continues to operate on that lie. And the mechanisms to change, you know, question the underlying gears of this thing are gone. So when the Stardy study had, was deconstructed in this way by the riot team, and they realized that nothing that you were supposed to take away from the study is what the data and the study actually said. There was this bigger kind of result of that that they took away. Researchers like the riot team that were kind of the outsider, you know, researchers, started doing studies where,
它继续基于那个谎言运作。而改变的机制，你知道，质疑这个东西底层齿轮的机制已经消失了。所以当Stardee研究被Riot团队以这种方式解构时，他们意识到你本应从研究中得出的结论并不是数据和研究实际所说的。他们从中得出了一个更大的结果。像Riot团队这样的研究人员，他们是那种局外人，你知道，研究人员，开始做研究，
they were taking apart or they wanted to take apart recent papers from different leading psychology journals that are getting cited everywhere, you know, kind of stopping this from happening again. And it had been peer reviewed and then been published. And I mean, other, you know, I have friends that like work at CERN and these hard science places. And peer review does not look like it looks like in psych there. In psych, you have kind of like five weirdos opinions. and then they usually contradict, so you can't really implement them.
他们正在拆解，或者他们想拆解来自不同领先心理学期刊的、到处被引用的近期论文，你知道，某种程度上阻止这种情况再次发生。而且它们经过了同行评审，然后被发表了。我的意思是，其他，你知道，我有朋友在CERN（欧洲核子研究中心）和这些硬科学地方工作。同行评审看起来不像心理学界那样。在心理学中，你有那种像五个怪人的意见，然后它们通常是矛盾的，所以你无法真正实施它们。
And then if you have enough money, you can publish a paper. Like that, I'm sorry, like I know a lot of researchers, like I've been involved in research, peer review and psych, if you've got enough money
然后如果你有足够的钱，你可以发表一篇论文。就像那样，我很抱歉，就像我认识很多研究人员，就像我参与过研究，心理学中的同行评审，如果你有足够的钱
and you want to publish something with a premise that's too stupid to say out loud, that's essentially like an op-ed, you can publish those. And, you know, so they wanted to take the papers that had passed all of these gates. and they had, you know, had total empirical credibility.
并且你想发表一篇前提太愚蠢而无法大声说出来的论文，这本质上就像一篇评论文章，你可以发表这些。而且，你知道，所以他们想拿走那些通过了所有这些关卡的论文。而且它们，你知道，拥有完全的经验可信度。
And then they would just simply try and reproduce them. If it's scientific and you're saying that we should act on this because it's reproducible and you controlled for everything, let's go ahead and do the same thing again. The study will, you know, reproduce itself. So they started trying to do that. And of hundreds of these original studies, only 36 were successfully replicated that were kind of the benign, least influential or at least threatening to the industry. And, you know, of the ones that were nominally replicated, the effect sizes in the replication were like, on average, half the size reported in the original papers.
然后他们就会简单地尝试复制它们。如果它是科学的，并且你说我们应该根据这个采取行动，因为它是可复制的，而且你控制了一切，让我们继续再做同样的事情。研究会，你知道，自我复制。所以他们开始尝试这样做。在数百项这些原始研究中，只有36项被成功复制，这些研究属于那种良性的、影响力最小或对行业威胁最小的研究。而且，你知道，在那些名义上被复制的研究中，复制中的效应量平均只有原始论文中报告的一半。
So I'm talking about hundreds of papers here that were failed to be replicated. Like, I can't go through each one, which one was CBT, which one was this medication paradigm versus that one, because this is already going to be boring and a data full episode talking about the way that research works, which, you know, even social workers dread learning at school. But none of them were really replicable. So they weren't contributing to any sort of thing that we could do in the future to avoid problems or to find solutions. And so that answer, largely from this movement, it turns out, you know, is that half the time you can't even replicate somebody else's data in the same world. It's not even close. And these are the ones that are supposed to be double blind and randomized controlled trial and huge sample sizes and multiple rounds of peer review. an internal replication and three teams replicating the same thing before we can say,
所以我在这里谈论的是数百篇未能被复制的论文。就像，我不能逐一列举，哪一个是CBT，哪一个是这种药物范式与那种药物范式的对比，因为这已经是一个无聊且充满数据的剧集，谈论研究运作的方式，你知道，即使是社会工作者也害怕在学校学习。但没有一个是真正可复制的。所以它们没有为我们未来可以做些什么来避免问题或找到解决方案做出任何贡献。所以那个答案，很大程度上来自这个运动，事实证明，你知道，有一半的时间你甚至无法在同一个世界里复制别人的数据。它甚至都不接近。而这些应该是双盲、随机对照试验、样本量巨大、多轮同行评审。内部复制和三个团队复制同一件事，然后我们才能说，
well, it happened in three or six rooms, so we can assume that it's going to happen in every room. These are like the big studies and they don't work. And that's not a small problem. Like the published literature of a science is supposed to be the cumulative record of what is known. And in the 70s, we were writing journals where there were techniques that you could use in the room. And there was subjective wisdom. You can open a journal and somebody says like, hey, I think that there's like an intercritic that shows up and it tells people that they are not good enough and it tends to team up with like
好吧，它在三个或六个房间里发生了，所以我们可以假设它会在每个房间里发生。这些就像大型研究，但它们不起作用。这不是一个小问题。就像一门科学的已发表文献应该是已知事物的累积记录。在70年代，我们编写的期刊里有你可以在房间里使用的技术。而且有主观智慧。你可以打开一本期刊，有人说，嘿，我认为有一个“内在批评者”出现了，它告诉人们他们不够好，而且它倾向于与一个“推动者自我”联手。
a pusher self. Now, intercritic and pusher are not real things. They're useful metaphorical lenses, but they're hard to measure because they're psychological concepts. Well, how are you going to research psychology without psychological concepts? If you open a medical journal in psych now, what you get is all these people doing meta-analysis, so that they can be cited by other papers, so that their score goes up,
现在，内在批评者和推动者不是真实的东西。它们是有用的隐喻镜头，但它们很难衡量，因为它们是心理学概念。好吧，你打算如何在没有心理学概念的情况下研究心理学？如果你现在打开一本心理学医学期刊，你得到的是所有这些人在做荟萃分析，这样他们就可以被其他论文引用，这样他们的分数就会上升，
so that they look better as a researcher, they're more likely to get funded or hired by the university. That's not a really good system because there's nothing in these new medical journals, in these new psychology journals, and these new therapy journals, that is, one, interesting to me at all, but two, that I can take and use in the room.
这样他们作为研究人员看起来更好，他们更有可能获得资助或被大学聘用。那不是一个真正好的系统，因为这些新的医学期刊、这些新的心理学期刊、这些新的治疗期刊中，没有什么东西，第一，对我来说一点也不有趣，但第二，我不能拿来在房间里使用。
The subjectivity has been stripped out of it, and that means that everyone is kind of exiled. Who might just be talking in a subjective way about how to help somebody with something that's useful, and not hiding behind what Deodor Porter would call the metaphors from distance or the insecurity of numbers that have come to define the profession and have come to oil the machine.
主观性已经被剥离了，这意味着每个人都有点被流放了。那些可能只是以主观方式谈论如何帮助某人解决有用问题的人，而不是躲在迪奥多·波特（Theodore Porter）所说的“距离的隐喻”或“数字的不安全感”背后，这些已经定义了这个行业并润滑了这台机器。
There's a replication crisis that isn't really being acknowledged, and most of the replication crisis was around CBT. The idea that CBT was the best form of therapy that you could ever get was something that was found over and over and over again throughout the 90s, and insurance said, okay, we'll forget everything else. we haven't really been able to replicate that. When you look at actual clinical data,
有一个没有被真正承认的重复性危机，而大部分重复性危机是围绕CBT的。CBT是你所能得到的最好的治疗形式的想法，在整个90年代被一次又一次地发现，保险公司说，好吧，我们会忘记其他一切。我们并没有真正能够复制这一点。当你观察实际的临床数据时，
CBT is something that most their patients say, yeah, these are kind of some techniques about how to think differently to gaslight myself into filling well when I feel bad. And I don't like it and I'm leaving. Now, I mean, there could be a lot of reasons for that. Maybe CBT is the best thing ever, but we're not controlling for clinicians that are good.
CBT是大多数病人说，是的，这些是一些关于如何进行不同思考的技术，以便在感觉糟糕时通过煤气灯效应（gaslight）让自己感觉良好。我不喜欢它，我要离开。现在，我的意思是，这可能有很多原因。也许CBT是最好的东西，但我们没有控制优秀的临床医生。
We're just graduating anybody with a pulse. They can afford it. I don't know what the problem is. I'm not trying to do a research study to explain that. But what I'm saying is that that isn't replicable. And the problems, the reason it's not replicable is something that we don't want to discover because any of the answers to that question would be something that blow the industries functioning up.
我们只是让任何有脉搏的人毕业。他们负担得起。我不知道问题是什么。我不是在试图做一个研究来解释这一点。但我所说的是，那不是可复制的。而问题，它不可复制的原因是我们不想发现的东西，因为对那个问题的任何回答都会炸毁行业的运作。
And research has become designed not to do that. It's supposed to speak power to truth, not truth. not truth to power. And so the quieter problem in CBT literature is, you know, when patients leave a CBT trial a lot of the time, because they say that the therapy is not helpful, which part of the goal of therapy and part of the skill of being a therapist is to engage someone. You have to pull them into a place they haven't been before. You have to take them somewhere that they're not familiar with.
而研究的设计初衷不是为了那样做。它应该对真理说出权力，而不是真理。不是对权力说出真理。所以CBT文献中一个更安静的问题是，你知道，当病人在很多时候离开CBT试验时，因为他们说治疗没有帮助，而治疗的目标之一和作为治疗师的技能之一是吸引某人。你必须把他们拉到一个他们以前没去过的地方。你必须带他们去一个他们不熟悉的地方。
You have to give them a new perspective pretty quickly. And if you don't, they should live. leave because that's part of the art, right? Which, you know, is hard to turn into a number. But when a CBT patient leaves a trial because they say, I've already tried this, I saw it on the Sopranos, like I've already read the self-help books, I've already watched the YouTube, this just doesn't feel helpful. I'm getting out at Session 7. They're just removed from the study. That doesn't prove that CBT doesn't work because the patient didn't complete 12 sessions. Well, who are you left with when you have people that say, I am so beaten down, I am so broken. I am so broken.
你必须很快给他们一个新的视角。如果你不这样做，他们就应该离开。离开，因为那是艺术的一部分，对吧？这，你知道，很难变成一个数字。但当一个CBT病人因为他们说“我已经试过了，我在《黑道家族》里看到了，就像我已经读过自助书了，我已经看过YouTube了，这感觉根本没帮助。我在第七次咨询时要退出”而离开试验时。他们只是被从研究中移除了。这并不能证明CBT不起作用，因为病人没有完成12次咨询。好吧，当你剩下那些说“我被击垮了，我太破碎了。我太破碎了”的人时，你还剩下谁？
I am just such a workhorse of it doing what daddy told me to do that I'm going to keep going to 12 sessions when I knew it session two it didn't work. I mean, that seems like something that contaminates the science to me. That is tautology dressed as evidence. And the patients who could have told you something important about the limits of the models are precisely the patients whose voices are not in the data set because they didn't complete the intervention. But the intervention's job is to get people. to participate in it because it's a relational science and it's a relational process but not when you're studying it this way and so there's a deeper move underneath all this and I want to name it because in my view the actual rhetorical capture that the apparatus pulled off the phrase evidence-based practice
我只是一个做着爸爸告诉我做的事情的苦力，以至于我会坚持到12次咨询，尽管我在第二次咨询时就知道它不起作用。我的意思是，这对我来说似乎是污染科学的东西。那是伪装成证据的同义反复。而那些本可以告诉你关于模型局限性的重要信息的病人，恰恰是那些声音不在数据集中的病人，因为他们没有完成干预。但干预的工作是让人们参与其中，因为它是一门关系科学，是一个关系过程，但当你这样研究它时就不是了，所以这一切之下有一个更深层的举动，我想命名它，因为在我看来，机构实现的实际修辞捕获，“循证实践”这个短语
or evidence-based therapy has been quietly redefined to mean something that it wasn't really supposed to mean you know, if you just look at the definition of those words. You know, Jonathan Shedler, who's interesting, you know, he's written, he's a psychoanalyst, he's Freudian leading. You know, he's written some of the most careful and, you know, as someone who's familiar with the process, they're not just critiquing it. Careful and nuanced critiques of all of it. You know, evidence-based practice therapy sounds like it should mean therapy based on evidence,
或“循证治疗”已经被悄悄地重新定义，以意味着它本不应该意味着的东西，你知道，如果你只看这些词的定义。你知道，乔纳森·谢德勒（Jonathan Shedler），他很有趣，你知道，他是一位精神分析学家，弗洛伊德派倾向。你知道，他写了一些最仔细的，而且，作为熟悉这个过程的人，他们不仅仅是在批评它。仔细且细致的批评。你知道，“循证实践治疗”听起来应该意味着基于证据的治疗，
and any thoughtful clinician would sign up for that. Of course, studying, causing effect, how could that hurt? anything. But the term as it's actually used in licensure boards and insurance protocols and graduated training programs and clinical practice guidelines as I would find out in the hospital has come to mean something narrow and strange. It means manualized therapy of the kind that can be tested in randomized controlled trials. That doesn't mean evidence based. It means randomized controlled trial therapy that turns everything into a number while it's doing it. They can be replicated by another clinician. And I've met some of the best clinicians in the world and I like them and I've talked to
任何有思想的临床医生都会报名参加。当然，研究因果关系，那怎么会伤害任何东西呢？但这个词在执照委员会、保险协议、研究生培训项目和临床实践指南中实际使用的含义，正如我在医院发现的那样，已经变得狭隘而奇怪。它意味着那种可以在随机对照试验中测试的手册化治疗。那并不意味着循证。它意味着随机对照试验治疗，在进行过程中把一切都变成数字。它们可以被另一位临床医生复制。我见过一些世界上最好的临床医生，我喜欢他们，我谈论过
them. I can't replicate what they do. I can take it and I can make it inform what I do. But I can't turn it into a formula. And I don't think that any of the people who have studied with me or gone through supervision with me or the patients who have seen being gone and become therapist can take what I do and turn that into something that they can replicate as a formula either. I don't think therapy, I think therapy itself is outside of that paradigm. If you put it in that paradigm, you're forgetting what it is and you're reducing what it is. So these protocols that they want are almost always brief. They're almost always cognitive behavioral.
他们。我无法复制他们所做的事情。我可以借鉴它，我可以让它为我的工作提供信息。但我不能把它变成一个公式。而且我不认为任何与我一起学习过，或者经过我督导，或者见过我并成为治疗师的病人，能够拿走我所做的事情并将其变成他们也可以复制的公式。我不认为治疗，我认为治疗本身就在那个范式之外。如果你把它放在那个范式里，你就忘记了它是什么，你就在贬低它是什么。所以他们想要的这些协议几乎总是简短的。它们几乎总是认知行为的。
And they're almost always with these pre-specified symptom reduction outcomes measured on standardized instruments. You're not allowed to create change. that you didn't intend. Well, I'm sorry. Therapy that is good creates changes all over the place that it didn't intend. The whole idea of evidence-based therapy on its own narrow methodological terms is built for a population and a kind of therapy that does not exist in the real world. It can't. Yet it controls the real world. And the conclusions drawn from this idea by licensure boards, by insurance companies, by professional guidelines,
而且它们几乎总是带有这些在标准化工具上测量的预先指定的症状减轻结果。你不被允许创造你没有打算创造的改变。好吧，我很抱歉。好的治疗会在各处创造它没有打算的改变。循证治疗本身在其狭隘的方法论术语上，是为现实世界中不存在的人群和治疗类型而建立的。它不能。然而它控制着现实世界。而执照委员会、保险公司、专业指南从这个想法中得出的结论，
you know, all the real world institutions that run our world is that it can still. And no one really seems to be on my side. I mean, they'll go to you, they'll go, like, with you to the bar and tell you this stuff.
你知道，所有运行我们世界的现实世界机构，是它仍然可以。而且似乎没有人真正站在我这边。我的意思是，他们会去，他们会去，像，和你一起去酒吧，告诉你这些东西。
People don't really seem to be interested in saying it professionally in the way that I am. And maybe that's because I'm stupid and I'm painting a target on my back. But honestly, like after 10 years in this world, like, I can't really live with myself anymore. I'm not saying the whole thing's bullshit. I'm not trying to blow it up. I'm just saying like, this is a pretty simple idea that like 85-ish percent of the good clinicians that I talk to
人们似乎并不真的有兴趣像我这样专业地表达它。也许那是因为我很蠢，我在给自己画靶子。但老实说，在这个世界待了10年之后，就像，我真的不能再忍受自己了。我不是说整个事情都是胡扯。我不是想炸掉它。我只是说，这是一个非常简单的想法，就像我交谈过的85%左右的好临床医生
will just tell you, yeah, of course it works like that. We just have to do what we can around that system, but we can't change it. Why? Why can you not change it? So if you want somebody's opinion about this other than mine, again, Jonathan Shedler is probably the guy to look at. I think that he makes probably the better case that CBT is this load-bearing wall of American psychology. And you know, it's what insurance pays for, what graduate programs teach, what gets called evidence-based practice like we talked about already. But his meta-analysis, they're good at picking apart the quality of why that wall is getting thinner. So Johnson and Freiburg 2015, that's one that I cite in my book a lot, which hopefully will come out in a year or two whenever it gets peer-reviewed. But in psychological bulls, and they talk about how CBT for depression across multiple decades, different effect sizes, it declined.
会直接告诉你，是的，当然是那样运作的。我们只是必须在那个系统周围做我们能做的事，但我们不能改变它。为什么？为什么你不能改变它？所以如果你想要除了我之外的某人对此的意见，再次，乔纳森·谢德勒可能是要看的人。我认为他可能提出了更好的理由，即CBT是美国心理学的承重墙。而且你知道，这是保险支付的，研究生项目教授的，被称之为循证实践的东西，就像我们已经谈过的那样。但他的荟萃分析，他们擅长剖析那堵墙为什么变薄的质量。所以Johnson和Freiburg 2015，那是我在我的书中经常引用的一个，希望它会在一两年内出版，无论它什么时候经过同行评审。但在心理学公报中，他们谈论CBT治疗抑郁症在过去几十年里，不同的效应量，它下降了。
The effect size and the advocacy at all. And that trend was statistically significant, and it continued across time. CBT got worse from the time when it had been validated as this gold standard across, you know, five-year, two-year and ten-year periods. So, you know, earlier studies showed these huge effects. and then the effects decreased. So later studies showed effects that on their own would never have justified building the whole paradigm that we built in the first place.
效应量以及所有的倡导。这种趋势在统计学上是显著的，并且随着时间的推移持续存在。认知行为疗法（CBT）从被验证为黄金标准的那一刻起，在五年、两年和十年的时间跨度里，效果反而变差了。所以，你知道，早期的研究显示了巨大的效应，然后这些效应就减弱了。因此，后来的研究显示出的效应，如果单独来看，根本不足以支撑我们最初建立的整个范式。
And, you know, Christia is one of the people who responds to Shedler a lot and defends CBT and says, hey, no, actually it hasn't gotten that bad or you're exaggerating things or you need to tighten your research to see how good it actually is, even though it's getting slowly worse or something. So, you know, Christia tightened the criteria for what counts as a real randomized controlled trial. And he said, when you do that, the decline goes away. You just have to have stronger, more double-blinded, more randomized controlled trials that have these features. And then, if you consider that as evidence, it proves that CBT is validated on an evidence-based practice level in these experiments.
而且，你知道，克里斯蒂亚（Christia）是经常回应谢德勒（Shedler）并为CBT辩护的人之一，他说，嘿，不，实际上它并没有变得那么糟糕，或者你夸大了事实，或者你需要收紧你的研究标准来看看它到底有多好，尽管它正在慢慢变差之类的。所以，你知道，克里斯蒂亚收紧了什么才算真正的随机对照试验的标准。他说，当你这样做时，这种衰退就消失了。你只需要拥有更强大、更双盲、更随机的对照试验，并具备这些特征。然后，如果你把这视为证据，它就证明了CBT在这些实验中达到了循证实践的验证水平。
But read what he's actually saying. He's saying in a vacuum that doesn't exist in any clinical setting, not real-world data. Just an experiment that you could do with certain controlled treatment holds. You can make this thing still behave like it did the first time that we proved it worked in a lab. Clinicians can't reproduce those conditions, dude. Like, why publish that paper? Patients don't live inside of studies. They live inside of life, and they live inside of decades that are progressively moving forward and changing things.
但读读他到底在说什么。他说的是在一个临床环境中根本不存在的真空状态，而不是真实世界的数据。这只是一个你可以用某些受控治疗手段进行的实验。你可以让这东西表现得像我们第一次在实验室证明它有效时那样。临床医生无法重现那些条件，伙计。那么，为什么要发表那篇论文呢？病人不是生活在研究中。他们生活在现实生活中，生活在不断前进并改变事物的几十年里。
At least, you know, we're kind of stuck in the 80s, but whatever. So, you know, the apparatus has become a closed loop, and you're not disproving that by saying that like when you do science a certain way, you get the same result. The question is not that. As we talked about in that cybernetics episode, the question is not does the math work? The question is, does the math replicate reality in a way that the math is useful? That's what science is. You know, Drew Weston is another one with Shedler that's made this point for years. You know, that patients in these trials are not the patients that walk into the offices. If you look at the average patient in America and you look at the average patient in a CBT study, the committed,
至少，你知道，我们有点被困在80年代了，但无所谓。所以，你知道，这个机制已经变成了一个闭环，你不能通过说“当你以某种方式做科学研究时，你会得到同样的结果”来反驳这一点。问题不在于此。正如我们在那期控制论节目中讨论的那样，问题不在于数学是否成立。问题在于，数学是否以一种有用的方式复制了现实？这就是科学。你知道，德鲁·韦斯顿（Drew Weston）是另一位多年来一直与谢德勒持相同观点的人。你知道，这些试验中的病人并不是走进诊室的那些病人。如果你看看美国的普通病人，再看看CBT研究中的普通病人，那些……
the comorbidities and the trauma history and the messy life circumstances, they're all screened out because they would make the data of this study too noisy. But you can't kill the ghost in the machine. Like, it's not that I want psychotherapy to be weird or it's not that I want psychology to be weird. It's that psychology is weird. And if you need it to not be that, you may just not be weird enough to study it. You should be in another science, maybe a harder science. You know, we run the treatment on a patient who doesn't exist in clinical practice, and then we call that result evidence of what that you could do something if you wanted to do well everyone knew that anyway does that thing mimic real life and the thing that we do in research like increasingly
合并症、创伤史和混乱的生活环境，它们都被筛选掉了，因为它们会让研究数据变得太嘈杂。但你无法消除机器里的幽灵。这不是说我想要心理治疗变得古怪，也不是说我想要心理学变得古怪。而是心理学本身就是古怪的。如果你需要它不那么古怪，那你可能还不够古怪，无法研究它。你应该去从事另一门科学，也许是一门更硬的科学。你知道，我们对一个在临床实践中不存在的病人进行治疗，然后我们称该结果为证据，证明如果你想做某事就能做到——好吧，反正每个人都知道这一点——那东西能模仿现实生活吗？而我们在研究中所做的事情，越来越……
doesn't at all anywhere and i need to curb some of my own like opining because this is already such a dense episode that has to summarize so many things that are not on their face interesting but like the assumption underneath all of this is that you can arrive at this intervention that understand psychology and then it will work forever, that things don't change, which is wild, because other professions that bump up against psychology don't assume that. Like if you said in 1955, this ad sells the best coal cream, you wouldn't be like, okay, we arrived at the best commercial ever,
一点也不像，我需要克制一下我自己的观点，因为这已经是一个非常密集的一集了，必须总结这么多表面上看起来并不有趣的事情，但这一切之下的假设是，你可以得出一个理解心理学的干预措施，然后它就会永远有效，事物不会改变，这太疯狂了，因为其他与心理学碰撞的职业并不这样假设。就像如果你在1955年说，这个广告卖的是最好的冷霜，你不会说，好吧，我们得到了有史以来最好的商业广告，
let's just air it forever. You would still be aware that that thing would need to change that you couldn't use the model that you made to make this coal cream ad, sell coal cream or, you know, what the next thing is to the next generation, because people evolve this, you know, basically immune system response to advertising, to where it looks dated, it looks bad. Therapy is the same. You know, anyone in advertising would know that.
让我们永远播放它吧。你仍然会意识到那东西需要改变，你不能用你制作这个冷霜广告的模型，去向下一代推销冷霜，或者你知道，下一代产品是什么，因为人们进化出了这种，你知道，基本上是对广告的免疫系统反应，以至于它看起来过时了，看起来很糟糕。治疗也是一样。你知道，广告界的任何人都知道这一点。
Why doesn't psychotherapy know this about itself? The culture absorbs the technique. But psychology has built itself on top of this opposite assumption that the mind is more like a chemical reaction that can be studied than a conversation and a reaction to the culture or a counterbalancing force, which is why it can't respond to, problems that the culture creates. CBT probably was markedly more effective than psychoanalysis in 1965.
为什么心理治疗不了解自己这一点呢？文化吸收了这种技术。但心理学建立在相反的假设之上，即心灵更像是一种可以被研究的化学反应，而不是一种对话、一种对文化的反应或一种制衡力量，这就是为什么它无法应对文化所产生的问题。在1965年，CBT可能确实比精神分析法有效得多。
But when you watch the effect sizes go away, it's not that it was a reduction then, and it isn't now. It always was. That reduction was useful because psychoanalysis was a bloated mess and the culture was less complicated. And now, the kind of anxiety that the current American can and needs to sit with to get better is vastly bigger and more complicated than it was in the future. 50s or the 60s. So you're not watching a treatment fail. You're watching a culture eat it because
但当你看着效应量消失时，并不是说当时有减少，而现在没有。它一直都在减少。这种减少是有用的，因为精神分析法是一个臃肿的烂摊子，而当时的文化也没那么复杂。现在，当代美国人为了好转所能且需要承受的那种焦虑，比50年代或60年代要大得多，也复杂得多。所以你看到的不是一种治疗方法的失败。你看到的是一种文化正在吞噬它，因为……
the treatment can't change in response to the culture. And the first time somebody hears in 1978 that their thoughts are not facts, that hits and they're like, well, my dad didn't do that. Wow, he never told me this. The 100th time after wellness apps and HR trainings and TikTok therapists and multiple cults that have integrated this information and advertising, the patient walks in already fluent in CBT running it on themselves badly as the center critic. And then the clinical room has nothing left to offer that they haven't already heard. Worse. They're just hearing the same thing that they've heard already from a therapist who's supposed to contain a different answer. And so the decline is evidence that CBT was real. It worked well enough that the culture
这种治疗方法无法随着文化的变化而改变。当有人在1978年第一次听到“你的想法不是事实”时，那会产生冲击，他们会想，嗯，我爸爸没那样做。哇，他从来没告诉过我这个。而在健康应用程序、人力资源培训、TikTok治疗师和多个整合了这些信息和广告的邪教之后，第100次听到这句话时，病人走进诊室时已经对CBT非常精通，并以自我批评者的身份糟糕地运行着它。然后临床室里就没什么可提供的了，他们都已经听过了。更糟糕的是，他们只是在从一个本应提供不同答案的治疗师那里听到他们已经听过的内容。所以这种衰退证明了CBT曾经是真实的。它工作得足够好，以至于文化……
metabolized it, and now it doesn't. It doesn't have the leverage that it once had because the leverage came partly from novelty and authority. And maybe that doesn't sound scientific. So I don't know that it will ever be found as a result by science. But the same point cuts the other way. The depth and semantic traditions that don't show up well in this kind of trial aren't failing. The measurement is not built to see them. It actually can't because they discover things that were never a goal of therapy in the first place, but are a goal of humanity and are a goal of psychology or should be.
代谢了它，现在它不再有效了。它不再拥有曾经拥有的杠杆作用，因为这种杠杆作用部分来自于新奇感和权威性。也许这听起来不科学。所以我不知道科学是否会将其作为结果发现。但同样的观点也适用于反面。那些在这种试验中表现不佳的深度和语义传统并没有失败。这种测量方法根本不是为了观察它们而建立的。它实际上做不到，因为它们发现的东西从来都不是治疗的目标，但却是人类的目标，也是心理学的目标，或者应该是。
And you can't put brain spotting on TikTok and inoculate the culture against it. You can't manualize the moment a patient's shoulders, for the first time in 20 years and they realized that they always went up every time I got angry. So the replication crisis in CBT, and we'll talk about brain spotting later, I realize I haven't mentioned it yet and just mentioned it now. But the replication crisis in CBT taken seriously is not a crisis of CBT. It is a crisis of the apparatus's ability to know what it has been measuring or what measurements mean. To cut to the chase of the replication crisis in CBT and to just get to the meat of it. So this series is supposed to be talking about the way that American psychotherapy was changed and captured by certain forces.
你不能把“大脑定位”（brain spotting）放到TikTok上，让文化对它产生免疫。你无法将病人肩膀的瞬间手册化，那是20年来第一次，他们意识到每次我生气时肩膀都会耸起。所以CBT中的复制危机——我们稍后会谈到大脑定位，我意识到我还没提到它，现在提到了——但认真对待CBT中的复制危机，并不是CBT的危机。这是该机制了解它一直在测量什么，或者测量意味着什么的能力的危机。直奔CBT复制危机的主题，直接切入核心。所以这个系列本应讨论美国心理治疗是如何被某些力量改变和捕获的。
As you get closer to the present, maybe I step on more people's toes. But again, like, I'm just reading you history and the way that these forces operate and the way that I see them affecting the clinical room from this top level, from 100 years ago to right now. So this is just history, guys. You have to understand this next bit as something that is explaining to you why. academia is confused, why it intentionally confuses itself, and why well-meaning people cannot tell real authority in soft science research from bullshit, basically. And I'm not calling all of it bullshit. I'm saying it's more confused than it used to be. And this is a net, not a cloth. I'm not going to weave every point together, but this moment, the same moment that CBT's happening, the same
随着你越来越接近现在，也许我会踩到更多人的脚趾。但再说一次，我只是在向你解读历史，解读这些力量运作的方式，以及我从这个顶层视角看到的它们如何影响临床室，从100年前到现在。所以这只是历史，伙计们。你必须把接下来的部分理解为是在向你解释为什么学术界感到困惑，为什么它故意让自己困惑，以及为什么好心人基本上无法分辨软科学研究中的真正权威和胡说八道。我并不是说所有这些都是胡说八道。我是在说它比过去更混乱了。这是一张网，而不是一块布。我不会把每一个点都编织在一起，但这个时刻，CBT发生的同一时刻，同一……
moment that Reagan is happening, the same moment where my industry goes off the wheels, it is related to forces in business, it is related to forces in politics. There's no way for me to do this honestly and not point that out. And you know, you infer what you want to. In August of 1971, Lewis Powell, who's a corporate lawyer, he writes this 38-page memorandum to the United States Chamber of Commerce that changes more than really anybody outside of certain kinds of sociopolitical fields would ever realize the influence of. And it's publicly available. I recommend that you Google this because it takes five minutes to read it. Unlike a lot of the things that I say are good.
里根发生的同一时刻，我的行业失控的同一时刻，它与商业力量有关，与政治力量有关。我不可能诚实地做到这一点而不指出这一点。你知道，你想推断什么就推断什么。1971年8月，身为企业律师的刘易斯·鲍威尔（Lewis Powell）写了一份38页的备忘录给美国商会，这份备忘录的影响力比某些社会政治领域之外的任何人都意识到的要大得多。它是公开可查的。我建议你谷歌一下，因为它只需要五分钟就能读完。不像我说的很多好东西。
This is five minutes of your time. But, you know, this is, he declares war on the New Deal establishment, says that we're following this thing that is based on what people want. And what the evidence is saying is the best direction for the country to go in based on, based on its own goals, or what its own stated ends are. But those own stated ends of the country, maybe they have these messy consequences for corporations, for business, for the profit motive. We got to go back and we got to look at, you know, if that thing is really what we want. And so he argues that business has to fight back because there's this regulatory state that's saying that you have to do things that doesn't kill people or that at least makes the products that you're selling do the thing that they say they're doing, especially when they're around something like medical practice.
这只需要你五分钟的时间。但是，你知道，这是，他向“新政”体制宣战，说我们正在遵循这种基于人们想要什么的东西。而证据所说的是，基于国家自身的目标或其宣称的目的，国家前进的最佳方向是什么。但那些国家宣称的目的，也许它们对公司、对商业、对利润动机有这些混乱的后果。我们必须回去看看，那东西是否真的是我们想要的。所以他主张商业必须反击，因为存在这种监管国家，它说你必须做那些不会杀人，或者至少让你销售的产品做它们声称要做的事情的事情，特别是在涉及医疗实践之类的事情时。
And that this is inconvenient and it's too far. And so Powell says, you know, that there's this, you know, he calls it a cultural left, but we've already sort of looked at what the cultural left in America was. I think those people were going away anyway. I think they wanted the thing that was happening anyway to basically happen faster. So he says, business has to fight back and just regular lobbying is not enough. What's needed is this systematic construction. of an intellectual and ideological infrastructure.
而且这很不方便，太过分了。所以鲍威尔说，你知道，存在这种，你知道，他称之为“文化左派”，但我们已经审视过美国的文化左派是什么了。我认为那些人无论如何都会消失。我认为他们只是想让正在发生的事情更快地发生。所以他说，商业必须反击，仅仅常规的游说是不够的。需要的是这种系统性的构建……
And it needs to replace, you know, the scientific establishment. It needs to compete with universities on their own ground because they're doing this research. But really, they need to be doing what we want and not what they're doing. And this isn't 71. And so he targets specific things. He says there's these faculty members at elite schools. There's the public broadcasting infrastructure that's just share. sharing all this information for free.
一种知识和意识形态的基础设施。它需要取代，你知道，科学体制。它需要在大学自己的地盘上与它们竞争，因为它们在做这些研究。但实际上，它们需要做我们想要的，而不是它们正在做的。这不是71年。所以他瞄准了具体的事情。他说，精英学校里有这些教职员工。有公共广播基础设施，它只是免费分享所有这些信息。
There's investigative journalism that's telling people what companies are doing. There's these anti-corporate textbooks that are explaining how political change happened in the past. There's consumer advocacy where people are saying, hey, this product sucks. Did the company selling it break the law, number one? And then two, can consumers organize to demand, you know, better things? And then there's environmental regulators that don't want to see, or at least want the public to know about the cost on the planet that the company is doing. There's all these things that I don't like because they go against the profit motive. And this will come back to therapy,
有调查性新闻在告诉人们公司在做什么。有这些反企业的教科书在解释过去政治变革是如何发生的。有消费者倡导，人们在说，嘿，这个产品很烂。销售它的公司违法了吗，第一？然后第二，消费者能组织起来要求，你知道，更好的东西吗？还有环境监管机构，他们不想看到，或者至少想让公众知道公司对地球造成的代价。所有这些我不喜欢的事情，因为它们违背了利润动机。这会回到治疗上来，
I promise. But so he says, you know, what we should do is if there's wealthy donors who also see these guys as a bad guy like I do, they've got to kind of fund a parallel apparatus who build something that look like the same thing as the university. So think tanks, he suggests. and endowed professorships at the universities. You know, you approach the universities and you build a, you know, giant hall. And then you say, there's a couple people, I think, that could think about something interesting that need to be taken just as seriously as everybody else who got here based on merit. For free market meritocracy, we need to make sure we can buy some board seats.
我保证。但所以他说，你知道，我们应该做的是，如果有富有的捐赠者也像我一样认为这些家伙是坏人，他们必须资助一个平行的机制，建立一些看起来和大学一样的东西。所以他建议智库，以及大学里的捐赠教授职位。你知道，你接近大学，建立一个，你知道，巨大的大厅。然后你说，我认为有几个人可以思考一些有趣的事情，他们需要像其他基于功绩来到这里的人一样被认真对待。为了自由市场的精英管理，我们需要确保我们能买到一些董事会席位。
And he also says, you know, the legal foundations, the media operations, the people doing the news. these are worth investing at this level that, you know, no one really sees because it'll just come up. And also, you've got to look grassroots. So you've got to get people on the ground excited about something. And this is all coordinated and it's on message. And there's a group behind the scenes who's dedicated to making sure that this regulatory state looks like an enemy of freedom in the corporate sector. Because what Reagan did wasn't really enough. we had to make sure that we weren't against the system.
他还说，你知道，法律基金会、媒体运营、做新闻的人，这些都值得在这个层面上投资，你知道，没人真正看到，因为它会自然出现。而且，你必须着眼于基层。所以你必须让基层的人对某事感到兴奋。这一切都是协调一致的，并且是有针对性的。幕后有一个团队致力于确保这个监管国家看起来像是企业部门自由的敌人。因为里根所做的实际上还不够。我们必须确保我们不是在反对系统。
We were mistaken for the old system while both systems were competing. You didn't have a fight between two. You just sort of said, hey, look, this science looks a little bit better. Let's do that science at the same time that universities are doing science like it used to be done. And, you know, the 70s is wildly important to the series. That's why we jump to it from the past. It's why we jump, you know, back into it talking about these developments. because so many seeds of this stuff was then.
我们被误认为是旧系统，而两个系统正在竞争。你并没有在两者之间进行斗争。你只是说，嘿，看，这门科学看起来好一点。让我们做那门科学，同时大学也在做像过去那样做的科学。而且，你知道，70年代对这个系列来说非常重要。这就是为什么我们从过去跳到这里。这就是为什么我们跳，你知道，回到谈论这些发展。因为很多这些东西的种子都在那时。
And again, read the memo. If you think that that's not what it says, Google it and read it. It's not a French document. And it's referenced still by people who like the, you know, changes that it created. And so it's received as this strategic blueprint by a small group of very wealthy families
再说一次，读读那份备忘录。如果你认为它说的不是那样，谷歌一下读读它。它不是一份法文文件。而且它仍然被那些喜欢它所创造的变革的人所引用。所以它被一小群非常富有的家庭视为这份战略蓝图，
who really understood what he was putting down. The Koch family is one of them. You know, the Melanaires, the Coors family, the DeVos family, they've all referenced this guy. The Bradley's, the Olin's. You know, and so five decades in, this network would pour out now what totals into not even adjusted for inflation, billions of dollars into the construction of the same apparatus. You didn't used to have, like you ever wonder who pays for like the 500 million think takes publishing stuff that you can like go Google and they're always. researching this and those guys make a lot they're not you know uh university of Alabama they're not even like Harvard level payroll people and they just sort of sit
他们真正理解他所提出的东西。科赫（Koch）家族就是其中之一。你知道，梅隆家族（Melonaires）、库尔斯（Coors）家族、德沃斯（DeVos）家族，他们都引用过这个人。布拉德利（Bradley）家族、奥林（Olin）家族。你知道，所以五十年过去了，这个网络现在投入了总计——甚至没有根据通货膨胀调整——数十亿美元用于构建同样的机制。你以前没有，就像你有没有想过是谁在为那些出版东西的5亿个智库买单，你可以去谷歌一下，他们总是……
there with like the tweed suit and the elbow patches eating scotch eggs and publishing this stuff and they make 500,000 dollars a year in some cases um usually starting you know in the low six figures 100 150 120 I've known a couple of people that have gone that way uh they make a lot and who pays for that because, I mean, I don't know, I don't make that. Most people don't make that. That movement of who pays for them starts now. And so there's this, there's a lot of different things, like the Hoover Institution and the Atlas Network and the Federalist Society,
研究这个，那些家伙赚很多，他们不是，你知道，阿拉巴马大学的，他们甚至不是哈佛水平的工资水平的人，他们只是坐在那里，穿着粗花呢西装，带着肘部补丁，吃着苏格兰蛋，出版这些东西，他们一年赚50万美元，在某些情况下，通常起薪，你知道，在六位数的低端，10万、15万、12万。我认识几个走那条路的人，他们赚很多，谁为那个买单？因为，我的意思是，我不知道，我不赚那个。大多数人不赚那个。那个为他们买单的运动从现在开始。所以有很多不同的东西，比如胡佛研究所（Hoover Institution）、阿特拉斯网络（Atlas Network）和联邦党人协会（Federalist Society），
and they slowly begin to approach university science and say, hey, actually, we're doing science better. We're just doing it. There's a different way that's more efficient. They all do that. that in different language. You could write a book going through capital fund donors and donors trust and dark money pass-throughs and people have, which is why I'm not going to try and repeat all of it because there's better books out there if you care about that kind of thing. But you look at who's doing
他们慢慢开始接近大学科学，说，嘿，实际上，我们做得更好。我们只是在做。有一种更有效率的不同方式。他们都用不同的语言做这件事。你可以写一本书，梳理资本基金捐赠者、捐赠者信托（Donors Trust）和黑钱传递渠道，人们已经写过了，这就是为什么我不会尝试重复所有这些，因为如果你关心那种事情，有更好的书。但你看看谁在做……
research in the 50s and its universities. And you look at who's doing the majority of research around things that affect capital expenditure and human life and medical services that most people will encounter in their lifetime by the 90s, and it's not universities anymore. And why not? I mean, this is all tax deductible. You get to have a gala. You get to say, I'm giving the money away. It's not mine anymore.
50年代的研究，那是大学。你看看到了90年代，谁在做大部分影响资本支出、人类生活和大多数人在一生中会遇到的医疗服务的研究，那不再是大学了。为什么不呢？我的意思是，这都是可以抵税的。你可以举办一场晚会。你可以说，我正在把钱捐出去。它不再是我的了。
And it's all structured as charitable giving, and you can't really tell what these organizations do, and all of it is invisible to the person who's watching cable news is this person who's just watching cable news. and then a credentialed expert comes on from the super smart university of knowing big things about the thing that I am talking about right now.edu or dotgov or dot org. And they say some stuff. Well, you go back to the 50s and those people worked at colleges and they had sort of meritocracy weighed their way up through a hierarchy that had some problems and some blind spots,
而且这一切都被构建为慈善捐赠，你真的无法分辨这些组织在做什么，这一切对于看有线电视新闻的人来说都是不可见的，这个人只是在看有线电视新闻。然后一个来自“超级聪明的大学，知道关于我现在正在谈论的事情的大事”的认证专家出现了，网址是.edu或.gov或.org。他们说了一些话。好吧，你回到50年代，那些人在大学工作，他们通过某种有缺陷和盲点的等级制度，以某种精英管理的方式晋升，
but was sort of centralized and sort of based on merit that you knew what you were talking about. You look at the news now, the people who are making those decisions came from these think tanks. You can't really tell the difference, or at least the general public can't. And a lot of times, even people who were fairly educated, I mean, I've spent so much time hearing somebody say something that was really wild and then being like, where did this person come from? Okay, they won all these awards from these organizations, but where did they come from? Okay, they sit on the board of this company that writes all, or this think tank or this thing that has a benevolent sounding name, and they write all of these, like, important documents that I can get for free as PDFs on their different sites and things, and they publish, and they say that they have these PhDs, but like, where did they have them from? And, like, where did they come from? A lot of times you can't really tell where they came from.
但它是某种集中的，某种基于功绩的，你知道你在谈论什么。你现在看新闻，那些做出决定的人来自这些智库。你真的无法分辨区别，或者至少普通公众无法分辨。很多时候，即使是受过相当多教育的人，我的意思是，我花了很多时间听某人说一些非常疯狂的话，然后心想，这个人是从哪里来的？好吧，他们从这些组织赢得了所有这些奖项，但他们是从哪里来的？好吧，他们坐在那家写所有东西的公司董事会里，或者这个智库，或者这个名字听起来很仁慈的东西，他们写了所有这些，比如，重要的文件，我可以免费在他们的不同网站上获得PDF，他们出版，他们说他们有这些博士学位，但，他们是从哪里得到的？而且，他们是从哪里来的？很多时候你真的无法分辨他们是从哪里来的。
They just sort of showed up on the board, and the fact that they had authority was the reason that they should hold authority. which is my critique of the system. Not the private donor system, but like the organization of basically the organization of American psychology and the broader like American research establishment, you could no longer tell if people just showed up because they were appointed by somebody to something that sounded important and so they got to be important or they had done anything that really distinguished them. And you still can't. I mean, that's the game. It's become smoke and mirrors. And this does move into this American public education. It being restructured through standardized testing,
他们只是出现在董事会上，而他们拥有权威这一事实就是他们应该拥有权威的原因。这就是我对系统的批判。不是私人捐赠者系统，而是基本上美国心理学的组织，以及更广泛的美国研究体制，你再也无法分辨人们是否只是因为被某人任命到某个听起来很重要的职位上而出现，所以他们变得很重要，或者他们是否做了任何真正让他们脱颖而出的事情。你仍然无法分辨。我的意思是，这就是游戏。它已经变成了烟雾和镜子。这确实进入了美国公共教育。它通过标准化测试被重组，
which converted the embodied work of teaching into these measurable outputs. Just you could do the same series that I'm doing now in psychology and how this optimization and efficiency metricing of it and making sure it's accountable. But we've got to turn it to a number to make sure it works. How can we compare people unless we turn them into it? to a number. You could look at the effect on that of every field, which on its face is a good idea. I like accountability. But you look at how it's implemented and who's doing it and why they're doing it almost every time it's done in American culture. And it's not for a good reason and it's not by people
将具体的教学工作转化为这些可衡量的产出。你可以在心理学领域做我正在做的同一个系列，关于这种优化和效率指标化，以及确保它负责任。但我们必须把它变成一个数字来确保它有效。除非我们把人变成数字，否则我们怎么能比较他们呢？你可以看看这对每个领域的影响，表面上看这是一个好主意。我喜欢问责制。但你看看它是如何实施的，谁在做，以及为什么他们在美国文化中几乎每次这样做时都这样做。这不是为了一个好的理由，也不是由那些……
who care about the thing that they claim they want to make better. American economics is restructured. You know, the Keynesians go out. I don't want to make this too. big of a topic. But the same thing that I'm saying happened to psychology. I can't not mention that it happened to psychology because it happened to everything else, because everybody who would have cared quit paying attention. And everybody who said that they were going to care had a reason to go away in the next generation. But like, again, this is about psychotherapy. The death practitioners retired. The cohort that replaced them was trained inside a new structure. They weren't indoctrinated into a conspiracy. They didn't kill the dissenters. They didn't stifle a
关心他们声称想要改善的事物的人所做的。美国经济被重组了。你知道，凯恩斯主义者出局了。我不想让这成为一个太大的话题。但我所说的发生在心理学身上的事情。我不能不提它发生在心理学身上，因为它发生在其他一切事情上，因为所有本该关心的人都停止了关注。而所有说他们会关心的人，在下一代都有理由离开。但是，再说一次，这是关于心理治疗。深度治疗师退休了。取代他们的群体是在一个新的结构内受训的。他们没有被灌输进一个阴谋。他们没有杀死异见者。他们没有扼杀一场……
rebellion. They just said, this is the way it is now, and we're going to tell everybody who's a baby who's coming in, that it's always been this way. And that no other way ever makes sense, except that wasn't true, but no one knew. And this new structure looked like it worked because the older cohort was still sort of carrying the load-bearing weight of the thing until they weren't. And by the time the older cohort was gone, the rebuild had become structurally impossible. And the people who were sort of doing the thing that they didn't really know where it came from anymore, but had inherited from the older cohort were being incentivized not to do that anymore or to leave the field. You know, just like education, just like politics in a lot of cases, just like many fields of soft science research.
叛乱。他们只是说，现在就是这样，我们要告诉每一个进来的婴儿，它一直都是这样。而且没有其他方式是有意义的，除了那不是真的，但没人知道。这个新结构看起来有效，因为老一代人仍然在某种程度上承担着该事物的承重重量，直到他们不再承担。等到老一代人消失时，重建在结构上已经变得不可能了。而那些正在做他们已经不知道从哪里来的事情，但从老一代人那里继承下来的人，被激励不再那样做，或者离开这个领域。你知道，就像教育一样，就像很多情况下的政治一样，就像许多软科学研究领域一样。
And so you have all these people coming in that say, you know, where is the explanation for why these, things exist and then those people retire and everyone else is told oh they exist for this reason which on its face is kind of crazy but that fits the academy and they become the new normal if it's public education if it's federal civil service if it's the State Department if it's the labor movement if the pattern is general this capture of psychology was synchronized with the capture of every other meaning-bearing institution in American life and it's run on the same playbook funded by the same network operated
所以你有所有这些进来的人说，你知道，为什么这些东西存在的解释在哪里？然后那些人退休了，其他人被告知，哦，它们存在是因为这个原因，这表面上有点疯狂，但这符合学术界，它们成为了新常态。如果是公共教育，如果是联邦公务员制度，如果是国务院，如果是劳工运动，如果这种模式是普遍的，那么对心理学的这种捕获就与对美国生活中每一个其他承载意义的机构的捕获同步了，它运行在同样的剧本上，由同样的网络资助，操作在……
at the same timeline because it's the same thing and it's not one person and it's not a cabal it's a system it's a cold machine and the mental health apparatus specifically was restructured by exactly this networking through exactly these mechanisms and if you don't want to admit that not only do you not know psychology or the history of your profession you don't know the history of the contrary, because the DSM3 shipped in 1980, and Reagan is inaugurated in 81. Managed care emerged in the same window. The pharmaceutical industries direct-to-consumer advertising was made legal in 1997 by an FDA rule changed that almost nobody outside the industry understood the significance of
同样的时间线上，因为它们是同一回事。这不是一个人，也不是一个阴谋集团，它是一个系统，它是一台冷酷的机器。心理健康机制特别是由这种网络通过这些机制重组的。如果你不想承认这一点，你不仅不知道心理学或你职业的历史，你还不知道相反的历史，因为DSM-3在1980年发布，里根在81年就职。管理式医疗在同一窗口期出现。制药行业的直接面向消费者广告在1997年通过一项FDA规则变更合法化，几乎没有行业外的人理解其重要性……
at the time, and many people inside the industry did not. And the clinical encounter was financialized, and the diagnostic categories were standardized into billing codes to fit that model. And the treatment protocols were manualized into procedures that could be delivered by interchangeable providers under insurance authorization. And the entire intellectual infrastructure that might have resisted that
当时，行业内许多人也不理解。临床接触被金融化了，诊断类别被标准化为计费代码以适应那种模式。治疗方案被手册化为程序，可以在保险授权下由可互换的提供者提供。而所有可能抵制那种……
or even understood that it was happening was driven out. Of every other profession in these colleges or given competition that it couldn't compete with at the same time that the depth psychological tradition, the humanistic clinicians, the semantic practitioners, the contemplative traditions,
甚至理解它正在发生的事情的知识基础设施都被驱逐了。在这些大学里的每一个其他职业中，或者被给予了它无法竞争的竞争，同时深度心理学传统、人文主义临床医生、语义实践者、沉思传统，
were systematically defunded, marginalized, and excluded from the credentialing pathways that determined who got to call themselves a real clinician and do research and publish things that someone actually read. And when I say actually read, I'm not kidding. Because the people who I don't like that are like the star researchers who are the most important in the world based on citation scores, based on H indexes, and based on the journal impact factors that they publish in, no one reads them either. I'm not kidding, man.
被系统性地削减资金、边缘化，并被排除在决定谁能称自己为真正的临床医生、进行研究和发表有人真正阅读的东西的认证途径之外。当我说是“真正阅读”时，我不是在开玩笑。因为那些我不喜欢的，那些基于引用分数、基于H指数、基于他们发表的期刊影响因子而成为世界上最重要的明星研究人员，也没人读他们的东西。我不是在开玩笑，伙计。
Like more people read my blog, which is not good and I am not important than the most prestigious scientist in the world, anyone pulled their paper and said, hey, I want to use this in a clinical psychology therapy session because I want to be a good therapist. If you look at the amount of people that actually read those things, and I wish that there was a way to make journals release those metrics or that there was a metric at all that was trackable, like they claim, who actually used this, learned something, and that. and then did it with a patient and said upvote or like a Reddit score, simple stuff. Citation scores are the raw tally of how many times other academic papers have referenced a researcher's study. So if you write something really broadly, a lot of people cite it. And so that means that we don't write things that are interesting anymore. We write things that are op-eds in papers. And we write things that are subjective in books.
就像读我博客的人比世界上最负盛名的科学家还要多，有人拿过他们的论文说，嘿，我想在临床心理治疗中使用这个，因为我想成为一名好的治疗师。如果你看看真正阅读这些东西的人数，我希望有一种方法能让期刊发布这些指标，或者有一种可追踪的指标，就像他们声称的那样，谁真正使用了这个，学到了什么，然后和一个病人一起做了，并说“点赞”或像Reddit分数那样，简单的事情。引用分数是其他学术论文引用研究人员研究次数的原始统计。所以如果你写的东西非常广泛，很多人会引用它。这意味着我们不再写有趣的东西了。我们写的是报纸上的专栏文章。我们写的是书中的主观内容。
But we just, in academic journals where people are supposed to go for the institutional knowledge of the profession, we write these giant meta analyses that cite everything. So if you want to say anything, you got to cite me. And then that makes my H index go up, which is a metric that tracks the productivity and the impact of any clinician, which your advancement score is based on if you're trying to get tenure in these universities. And then the journals want more of both of these because that's a journal impact factor, a JIF, which measures the yearly average of how many people have cited your journal. So this is like SEO.
但我们只是，在人们本应去寻找职业机构知识的学术期刊中，我们写这些引用了一切的巨大荟萃分析。所以如果你想说什么，你必须引用我。然后这会让我的H指数上升，这是一个追踪任何临床医生生产力和影响力的指标，如果你试图在这些大学获得终身教职，你的晋升分数就是基于此。然后期刊想要更多这两者，因为那是期刊影响因子（JIF），它衡量你的期刊被引用的年度平均值。所以这就像SEO。
It's like the website that you go to where you're like, why did I end up on this website when I cite that I typed in this basic question, but Google is saying, well, this one has all this information that's like weird and a lot of things point to it so it's important. You're like, that's not what I want. It's not what I ask. But it's giving it to you because it meets this criteria. that is this cold machine.
这就像你访问的网站，你会说，为什么当我输入这个基本问题时，我最终会来到这个网站，但谷歌说，嗯，这个网站有所有这些奇怪的信息，而且很多东西都指向它，所以它很重要。你会说，那不是我想要的。那不是我问的。但它给了你，因为它符合这个标准，这就是那台冷酷的机器。
But if you go to how many clinicians have pulled a paper from one of these things, read it, used it, and done anything with it with a patient that affected their clinical practice in 100 years, not even like 50, like 100 years, you will watch it go down every year because it is just this game that we have to keep track of as the symbolic system to make sure that academia functions,
但如果你去看看有多少临床医生从这些东西中提取了一篇论文，阅读了它，使用了它，并用它对病人做了任何影响他们临床实践的事情，在100年里，甚至不是50年，而是100年，你会看着它每年都在下降，因为它只是我们必须追踪的游戏，作为确保学术界运作的象征系统，
which is part of this machine, man. my blog outranks how many people read this stuff and my blog is not good and I am not an important guy why is the readership for something that I say get more emails saying hey I use this than the academic journals that are supposed to make sure
这是这台机器的一部分，伙计。我的博客排名超过了阅读这些东西的人数，而我的博客并不好，我也不是一个重要的人。为什么我说的话的读者群收到的邮件说“嘿，我用了这个”比那些本应确保……
that clinical practice is evidence-based, scientific, and working and we're all informed by that as clinicians right if any of the people that care about the evidence-based practice paradigm or research think this is wrong go back and tell me what you have used that was made in the last 50 years that wasn't you know basically the forward to somebody's book that they were already going to publish like stephen porges and then they put it out on LinkedIn to get engagement there was actual a product actually you know made from the machine of the infrastructure that we have now. Because if you look at what people's PhD product was,
临床实践是循证的、科学的、有效的，而且我们作为临床医生都受此影响，对吧？如果任何关心循证实践范式或研究的人认为这是错的，回去告诉我你使用了什么在过去50年里制造出来的东西，而不是，你知道，基本上是某人已经要出版的书的前言，比如斯蒂芬·波格斯（Stephen Porges），然后他们把它放到LinkedIn上以获得互动，真的有一个产品，你知道，是由我们现在拥有的基础设施机器制造出来的。因为如果你看看人们的博士产品是什么，
it was I wanted to research this. I wanted to research that. But then I wasn't able to because my PhD advisor said that I couldn't. And then I found five PhD advisors that said that I, no one wanted to do the thing that I wanted to do. And then I found this one guy and then he said that I could. And what we compromised on was this screener that I came up with, which is a way to detect anxiety that is 50 questions.
它是“我想研究这个。我想研究那个。”但后来我不能，因为我的博士导师说我不能。然后我找到了五个博士导师，他们说我……没人想做我想做的事情。然后我找到了这个家伙，他说我可以。我们妥协的是我提出的这个筛查器，这是一种检测焦虑的方法，有50个问题。
Dude, if you need 50 questions to figure out if somebody has anxiety, get out of the field. And I realize that makes anxiety hard to research because, like, you don't know statistically for a study if they have it or not. If you don't know if they have it and you won't just say somebody can detect if somebody's anxious, you don't need to be a therapist. But my question stands. Like the other processes that we had before, the academic processes before the Powell stuff and the capture of academic. end upendium, essentially. They produced products that were new models of therapy, that were new innovative techniques. You go back and you look at what we have now, it's a repackaging. I mean, even IFS, that's just putting Jungian psychotherapy together with Christralt therapy in a way that you can
伙计，如果你需要50个问题来弄清楚某人是否有焦虑，那就离开这个领域吧。我意识到这使得焦虑很难研究，因为，你知道，在统计学上你不知道研究对象是否有焦虑。如果你不知道他们是否有焦虑，而且你甚至不愿说某人可以检测出某人是否焦虑，你就不需要成为一名治疗师。但我的问题依然存在。就像我们在鲍威尔事件和学术界被捕获之前拥有的其他过程一样，本质上是纲要。它们产生的产品是新的治疗模型，是新的创新技术。你回去看看我们现在有什么，这是一种重新包装。我的意思是，即使是IFS（内在家庭系统疗法），那也只是把荣格心理治疗与克里斯塔尔（Christralt）疗法结合在一起，以一种你可以……
teach to, you know, basically standardize enough to put inside of a treatment unit so that you don't have to have people sit in it for, you know, seven years until you can say that they're a Jungian therapist or something. And I like IFS fine, but what do we invent it? What is new? And what is new that the academic literature will let you pay attention to? I mean, we are very hostile to a lot of new models that are good because they're too weird. I'm sorry, not too weird. They are too complicated to be researched. They are not manualizable. They are not acceptable to a randomized controlled trial. And another thing, we're not willing to admit that the mechanism of action inherent in them may be too complicated for us to ever really understand. We may just be able to
教导的方式，你知道，基本上标准化到足以放入治疗单元中，这样你就不必让人坐在那里，你知道，七年，直到你可以说他们是荣格治疗师之类的。我喜欢IFS，但我们发明了什么？什么是新的？什么是学术文献会让你关注的新东西？我的意思是，我们对很多好的新模型非常敌视，因为它们太古怪了。抱歉，不是太古怪。它们太复杂了，无法研究。它们无法手册化。它们不被随机对照试验所接受。还有一件事，我们不愿意承认它们固有的作用机制可能太复杂，以至于我们永远无法真正理解。我们可能只能……
understand the conditions in which it arises in a therapeutic relationship with a certain kind of person and a certain kind of buy-in and a certain kind of process. We can't say, oh, well, here's the exact thing and what it did the brain. We may not really ever be able to do that. And if you're not going to be comfortable with that, I don't know how well you can research what I do. Going back broadly to how the emperor has no clothes in these systems after this time, but that everybody sort of assumes the emperor must have more clothes than they think they do because it's hard and scary to think about that. You know, I was talking about how there's this general property of institutions that happens across all of American life, which is why we
理解它在与某种人、某种认同和某种过程的治疗关系中产生的条件。我们不能说，哦，好吧，这就是确切的东西以及它对大脑做了什么。我们可能永远无法真正做到这一点。如果你对此不舒服，我不知道你能多好地研究我所做的事情。回到这些系统在此时此地为何“皇帝没穿衣服”的广泛话题，但每个人都假设皇帝一定穿了比他们想象中更多的衣服，因为思考这一点既困难又可怕。你知道，我一直在谈论机构有一种普遍的属性，这种属性发生在所有美国生活中，这就是为什么我们……
talk about politics and other things like on a series like this. It affects more. things than just CBT. Like CBT, again, I don't hate it. I don't hate the people who made it. I do it. I like and respect the founders of it. I don't like the way that the machine uses these things because it uses things in the way that even the people like we talked about with the DSM 4 and 5 or Aaron Beck, the people who made them said wrong, bad, don't do that with my creation. But this pattern continues. You know, there's an institution that carries a body of practical wisdom in the bodies and the habits and the tacit knowledge of one generation of practitioners. And if you want my take on the CBT, you know, replication crisis, this is what it is.
谈论政治和其他事情，就像在这个系列节目中一样。它影响的事物远不止认知行为疗法（CBT）。就像CBT，再说一次，我不讨厌它。我不讨厌创造它的人。我使用它。我喜欢并尊重它的创始人。我不喜欢机器使用这些事物的方式，因为它使用事物的方式，甚至连我们谈论过的DSM-4和DSM-5的制定者，或者亚伦·贝克（Aaron Beck）本人都说那是错的、糟糕的，不要用我的创造物做那种事。但这种模式仍在继续。你知道，有一个机构承载着一代从业者的身体、习惯和默会知识中的实践智慧。如果你想听听我对CBT“可重复性危机”的看法，这就是它的本质。
The wisdom of this profession does not live primarily in the manuals or in the techniques. It lives in the space between the numbers. And it doesn't live in training programs. It lives in like the way that we learn to feel with someone competent. And so there is a generational passing on that is the important thing that you can't measure. And so I think what happened is that you had people who came from depth schools in the 50s, 60s, 70s, even the 80s, because they were still functioning. They were still there. And then as they started to retire, even though they said what I'm doing is CBT, why these broads,
这个行业的智慧并不主要存在于手册或技术中。它存在于数字之间的空间里。它也不存在于培训项目中。它存在于我们学习如何与一个有能力的人产生共鸣的方式中。因此，有一种代际传承是至关重要的，而这是你无法衡量的。所以我认为发生的事情是，在50、60、70年代，甚至80年代，有一批来自深度心理学流派的人，因为他们当时还在工作。他们还在那里。然后当他们开始退休时，尽管他们说我做的是CBT，为什么这些……
studies that didn't look at randomized controlled trials only like Christia did, but the entire field said, wait a minute, as CB2 took over and it was the only thing that existed, outcomes got worse. You know, Christia would tell you, well, when you do this in a vacuum, CBT still works. Okay, fine, but when you trained to the real world to do it, which is the thing science is supposed to inform, all of a sudden the profession got worse over time. Why? I think people were still bringing in training and information and a mode of being that as they died or retired, which therapists are more likely to die than retire, by the way, the good ones, they do it until they die.
那些不仅仅像克里斯蒂亚（Christia）那样只看随机对照试验的研究，而是整个领域都说，等一下，随着CBT接管了一切，并且成为唯一存在的东西，结果反而变差了。你知道，克里斯蒂亚会告诉你，嗯，当你在真空中做这件事时，CBT仍然有效。好吧，没问题，但当你训练人们在现实世界中去做这件事时——这正是科学应该提供指导的地方——突然间，这个行业随着时间的推移变得更糟了。为什么？我认为人们仍然在引入培训、信息和一种存在模式，而随着他们去世或退休——顺便说一句，治疗师去世的可能性比退休大，那些优秀的治疗师会一直工作到死。
They left CBT to stand on its own merits because it was the people who were trained by the CBT teachers, not just all of the teachers and the CBT was what they had to do to bill insurance. I think it was there were these depth schools as as they died off, the profession as a whole got worse, but it doesn't know why. But we have to keep researching with randomized controlled trials to figure out why. And so we can't know. So it's not that the knowledge is lost or that I did it or that the system is bad. It's just that it's we can't really understand. We have to keep doing science the way that we do science.
他们让CBT依靠自身的优点站稳脚跟，因为是那些受过CBT老师培训的人，而不仅仅是所有的老师，而且CBT是他们为了向保险公司报销而必须做的事情。我认为是因为有这些深度心理学流派，随着他们逐渐凋零，整个行业变得更糟了，但它不知道原因。但我们必须继续用随机对照试验进行研究来找出原因。所以我们无法得知。所以并不是知识丢失了，或者我做了什么，或者系统很糟糕。只是我们真的无法理解。我们必须继续以我们做科学的方式做科学。
In psychotherapy, of course, through randomized controlled trials. trial because if we don't, how could we ever figure out the problem? But that solution to the problem was invented by people who never wanted you to know why the problem was there, because they didn't want to know why it was in the macro, bigger world, because they didn't want to know why it was in themselves. And that is this methodological trap. It's this structural argument that I've been trying to make this whole time. It's not a rhetorical point. It's grounded in the literature. if you read it, that, you know, the field has worked to keep, you know, this peripheral written, serious researchers using the field's own standards and absorbed into the apparatus's filing system,
在心理治疗中，当然是通过随机对照试验。因为如果我们不这样做，我们怎么能找出问题所在呢？但那个问题的解决方案是由那些从不想让你知道问题为什么存在的人发明的，因为他们不想知道为什么它存在于宏观的、更大的世界中，因为他们不想知道为什么它存在于他们自己身上。这就是那个方法论的陷阱。这就是我一直试图提出的结构性论点。这不是一个修辞点。它是有文献支持的。如果你读过它，就会发现，这个领域一直致力于保持这种边缘化的、严肃的研究人员使用该领域自己的标准，并被吸收到机构的归档系统中，
the same way other critiques of American policy or the American system have been absorbed. You know, those conclusions that Shedler and Weston came up with never really had a good rebuttal. You know, Christia didn't make one that worked. You know, but they haven't changed clinical practice, even though no one could rebut it. And they published in a scientific journal and they got a PhD, so it should have changed it, right? No, we don't follow science. Science follows money. They didn't change reimbursement.
就像对美国政策或美国系统的其他批评被吸收一样。你知道，谢德勒（Shedler）和韦斯顿（Weston）得出的那些结论从来没有得到过很好的反驳。你知道，克里斯蒂亚没有做出有效的反驳。你知道，但他们没有改变临床实践，尽管没有人能反驳它。而且他们发表在科学期刊上，他们获得了博士学位，所以它应该改变它，对吧？不，我们不遵循科学。科学遵循金钱。他们没有改变报销制度。
They didn't change the footnotes and articles that no one reads. You know, they didn't change the apparatus. It continues. is, the cold machine that we've made. In the actual therapy hour, the actual encounter between two people, the limit is not technical. The limit is human. The limit is how much the machine will free you to engage with your own humanity. And most patients are not wanting to go into theirs, and it's why the therapist, it's so important
他们没有改变那些没人读的文章的脚注。你知道，他们没有改变这个机构。它还在继续。这就是我们制造的冷酷机器。在实际的治疗时间里，在两个人之间的实际接触中，限制不是技术的。限制是人的。限制在于机器会释放多少让你去接触自己的人性。而大多数病人并不想进入他们自己的内心，这就是为什么治疗师，这非常重要，
to do it because, you know, I have so many people that say, I just feel human. I just feel good at the end of therapy. And at the beginning, I'm not a gun owner and I'm not advocating for violence, but like, had I held a gun to their head just rhetorically and said, you know, are you human? Do you feel human? Do you feel? Do you have emotions? They would have said yes. And at the end of therapy, they're telling me I didn't know how to do that. That's always been its job. Can this cold machine actually teach us how to do that? Because I don't think so. You know, the actual reason that most therapy doesn't produce results that we wish to produce increasingly as a contrary. And increasingly as therapists that haven't engaged with this history is not the absence of the right protocol or technique. It's the presence of the same defended structure on both sides of the encounter that increasingly the profit motive and the system make impossible to provide. And this is why providers are not better than they are. This is why patients do not get better. This is why the field has produced manualized protocols and checklists and PhD programs instead of things that you can open an academic journal and read and use.
去做这件事，因为，你知道，我有很多人说，治疗结束时我只是感觉像个人。我只是感觉很好。而在开始时，我不是枪支拥有者，我也不提倡暴力，但就像，如果我从修辞上用枪指着他们的头说，你知道，你是人吗？你感觉自己是人吗？你有感觉吗？你有情绪吗？他们会说是的。而在治疗结束时，他们告诉我我不知道该怎么做。那一直是它的工作。这台冷酷的机器真的能教我们怎么做吗？因为我不这么认为。你知道，大多数治疗不能产生我们日益希望产生的结果的真正原因，与此相反。而且作为没有参与这段历史的治疗师，这日益不是因为缺乏正确的方案或技术。而是因为在接触的双方都存在同样的防御结构，而利润动机和系统使得提供这种治疗变得不可能。这就是为什么提供者没有变得更好。这就是为什么病人没有好转。这就是为什么这个领域产生了手册化的方案、清单和博士项目，而不是你可以打开学术期刊阅读和使用的东西。
The protocol is a defense against the limits of the average clinician. It's not one that helps an excellent clinician excel. And when you do that, you don't make shitty clinicians better. You make good clinicians and excellent clinicians leave the field forever. And this is not a strategy for producing depth work. It's a strategy for trying to set the floor so that nobody feels embarrassed. But you felt embarrassed anyway. Go ahead and admit it and then get better.
方案是对普通临床医生局限性的一种防御。它不是帮助优秀临床医生出类拔萃的东西。当你这样做时，你并没有让糟糕的临床医生变得更好。你让优秀的临床医生和卓越的临床医生永远离开了这个领域。这不是产生深度工作的策略。这是一种试图设定底线，让没人感到尴尬的策略。但你还是感到尴尬了。继续承认它，然后变得更好。
And that's why the problem happens at the educational level. You know, graduate schools cannot admit that. They are selling education in something. But that thing is, at its essence, unteachable. And that's why they pretend for their... marketing that it has to be. And they pretend for their own graduation metrics about how many people left and got licensed and how many left and got whatever, that you just can teach it. You can teach protocols and you can teach the diagnostic framework. You can teach the ethics codes and the
这就是为什么问题发生在教育层面。你知道，研究生院不能承认这一点。他们正在销售某种东西的教育。但那东西，本质上是不可教的。这就是为什么他们为了营销而假装它是可教的。他们为了自己的毕业指标，关于有多少人离开并获得了执照，有多少人离开并获得了什么，而假装你可以教它。你可以教方案，你可以教诊断框架。你可以教道德准则和
documentation requirements and the assessment instruments, but you can't teach somebody how to sit with another person without flinching from what is actually present in the room. They kind of come in knowing that or they don't? Or they go into a program and they learn the parts of themselves they're afraid of, ideally, and they learn to deal with those, which increasingly, as we strip this language out of the profession, we don't do anymore. And a lot of the people that I make this argument, too, say like, hey, well, you know, the thing is that these things are like not hard sciences. You know, they haven't read Theodore Reporter, but they make this argument. I'm like, man, I have friends in the hard sciences. One of my close friends, like works for CERN and does quantum physics and programs,
文件要求和评估工具，但你不能教一个人如何与另一个人坐在一起，而不对房间里实际存在的东西退缩。他们要么进来时就知道，要么不知道。或者他们进入一个项目，理想情况下，他们学习自己害怕的部分，并学习如何处理这些部分，而随着我们从这个行业中剥离这种语言，我们不再这样做了。而且很多我向其提出这个论点的人说，嘿，嗯，你知道，问题是这些东西不是硬科学。你知道，他们没有读过西奥多·波特（Theodore Porter），但他们提出了这个论点。我说，伙计，我有在硬科学领域的朋友。我的一位密友，在欧洲核子研究中心（CERN）工作，做量子物理和编程，
basically the algorithms that make the magnets and the computer fire the particle. And this guy almost fell out of school a lot of times because they came to him and they were like, you're not good enough. You don't have it. You got in, you paid us money, and we're kicking you out. And that happens in STEM. It does not happen in social work. And that moment for him where they came him and they told him that at Vanderbilt. He was like, well, I need to get better. When I was in school, the peers that I have that no longer work in the profession who had issues when they got into the field, when they had problems, the school said, do you feel okay? What's wrong? Why did we let you in? You got into this program, so you must be good. They didn't say, hey, you have an obvious emotional
基本上是让磁铁和计算机发射粒子的算法。这家伙很多次差点被学校开除，因为他们找到他说，你不够好。你没有天赋。你进来了，你付了钱，我们要把你踢出去。这在STEM领域会发生。在社会工作领域却不会。对他来说，当他们在范德比尔特大学找到他并告诉他那一刻时。他想，好吧，我需要变得更好。我在学校时，我那些不再从事这个行业的同龄人，当他们进入这个领域时，当他们遇到问题时，学校会说，你感觉还好吗？怎么了？我们为什么要让你进来？你进入了这个项目，所以你一定很优秀。他们没有说，嘿，你有一个明显的心理
blind spot that is messing up your relationship with everyone in this program, all of your professors, and will prevent you from working in this field. And if you don't deal with it, you will never help a patient, ever, ever. And so why don't you do that if you really are honest about your drive to help people? Because I think that what you might be doing is mistaking other people for this version of yourself that needs to be enabled and you want to be enabled and that's not the real world. So are you okay? Can you get it together? And do you want to accomplish your own goals?
盲点，这正在搞砸你与这个项目中每个人的关系，你所有的教授，并将阻止你在该领域工作。如果你不处理它，你将永远、永远无法帮助任何病人。所以如果你真的对帮助他人的动力诚实，为什么不这样做呢？因为我认为你可能做的是把别人误认为是这个需要被赋能的你自己，而你想要被赋能，那不是现实世界。所以你还好吗？你能振作起来吗？你想实现你自己的目标吗？
And we're going to hold you accountable and make sure that you do. if you want to. That's something that I've never seen a psychology graduate school do ever in the last 10 years, ever, anywhere. Why? Why do hard sciences do that and we can't? You want to hide behind the language of hard science? Can you ask that question and tell someone,
如果你想的话，我们会让你负责并确保你做到。这是我在过去10年里，在任何地方，从未见过任何心理学研究生院做过的事情。为什么？为什么硬科学领域会那样做，而我们不能？你想躲在硬科学的语言后面吗？你能问那个问题并告诉某人，
do you want to be better at what you do? Do you want this to be something that you can own your own self enough to help examine in someone else? Your humanity. And that's where we are. You know, by the 2010s, this apparatus that we traced, you know, in the last episode, had its own empirical foundation systematically demolished in its own language, but it used that language to hide that fact from itself.
你想在你的工作中变得更好吗？你希望这成为你可以足够拥有自我，从而帮助检查别人身上的东西吗？你的人性。这就是我们所处的位置。你知道，到了2010年代，我们在上一集追踪的这个机构，其自身的实证基础在它自己的语言中被系统地拆除了，但它利用那种语言向自己隐瞒了这一事实。
You know, the flagship clinical trial of the medication first paradigm exposed as a methodological fiction that it doesn't know how to do what it claimed it did. And then it just said, well, maybe there's a reason for that. But we don't know what it is. yet, which is what happened with the DSM3, is it kept saying with the language of science, in the language of academic publishing, and the language of academic advancement and synod structures. Well, we must be right.
你知道，药物优先范式的旗舰临床试验被揭露为一种方法论上的虚构，它不知道如何做它声称做的事情。然后它只是说，嗯，也许这有一个原因。但我们还不知道它是什么，这正是DSM-3发生的事情，它一直用科学的语言、学术出版的语言、学术进步和同义结构的语言说。嗯，我们一定是正确的。
We just don't know why we're right yet, except we keep being proven wrong. Dude, how much more time do you need? The director of the federal research agency, in his own retrospective, said, I gave you $20 billion. And you failed to move the needle, not in a direction, but in any direction that was consistent. You just kept kind of saying stuff. So admit that's what the field is. Or go back and say, we don't know how to find biomarkers to diagnosis that we made up with
我们只是还不知道为什么我们是正确的，除了我们一直被证明是错的。伙计，你还需要多少时间？联邦研究机构的负责人在他自己的回顾中说，我给了你200亿美元。而你未能推动指针，不是在一个方向上，而是在任何一致的方向上。你只是不断地说一些东西。所以承认这就是这个领域。或者回去说，我们不知道如何找到我们一百年前用
Freudian language a hundred years ago. And I don't have an answer. I'm just saying you got to pick a direction. And then we get a scientific method. We got to make a hypothesis. We got to test the hypothesis. We got to see if it works. We got to admit when we were wrong, which is the place we're at now.
弗洛伊德语言编造的诊断的生物标志物。我没有答案。我只是说你必须选择一个方向。然后我们得到一个科学方法。我们必须做出假设。我们必须测试假设。我们必须看看它是否有效。我们必须在我们错了的时候承认，这就是我们现在所处的位置。
And then we got to go back and have another one. Pick one of those two directions. This wall is hollow and the wall continues to stand. Because by the time anyone proved that the wall was hollow, the wall had become structural and the structural removal would cost the institution too much more. money to remove. And this is the resting state of American psychiatry and the broader psychology that follows it as we enter this present moment. This is an apparatus operating on an empirical foundation that its own research enterprise has abandoned, a profession bifurcated between an academy
然后我们必须回去再做一个。选择那两个方向中的一个。这堵墙是空的，而墙继续矗立着。因为当有人证明墙是空的时候，墙已经变成了结构性的，而结构性的拆除将花费机构更多的钱来拆除。这就是美国精神病学及其追随的更广泛心理学在进入这一当下时刻的静止状态。这是一个建立在实证基础上的机构，而它自己的研究企业已经放弃了它，一个在学院之间分化的职业，
that knows the score and a clinic that cannot afford to know it, and patients sorted into categories that the federal government has declared invalid, whose insurance reimbursement is still precipitated on it working. Medications prescribed for indications barely distinguishable from placebo effect. In some cases, not all, and medication does have an effect. I've seen it. I'm just saying we don't quite know what that is, and that's a safer place for me to be as a human, then having the certainty of the machine. I can tell you what I've felt, what I've seen, and how I kind of know that they work being on interdisciplinary treatment teams and fighting with psychologists and psychiatrists about, no, but this is what I saw. Can we get this other thing? Well, the research
学院知道真相，而诊所却负担不起知道真相，病人被分类到联邦政府宣布无效的类别中，其保险报销仍然基于它有效。为与安慰剂效应几乎无法区分的适应症开出的药物。在某些情况下，并非全部，药物确实有效果。我见过。我只是说我们不太清楚那是什么，作为一个人类，这对我来说是一个更安全的地方，而不是拥有机器的确定性。我可以告诉你我的感受，我所看到的，以及我如何知道它们在跨学科治疗团队中工作，并与心理学家和精神科医生争论，不，但这正是我所看到的。我们能得到这个其他东西吗？嗯，研究
says, but every time he takes it, it goes this direction. And the psychiatrist on those teams was good. And they listened to me and said, okay, we'll try this one. Let's try and triangulate. It sounds like there's a mood thing. We've lost those conversations. And the wall is not all of psychiatrists. The wall is part of psychology that got captured. Underneath the wall, around the wall, in the cracks of the wall, in the basement, in the back rooms, and the private practices, and the supervision groups, and the somatic training, and the intensives, and the indigenous traditions, and all of the stuff that most good psychologists are interested in, where they actually obtain wisdom and not obtain merit.
说，但每次他服用它，它就朝着这个方向发展。那些团队中的精神科医生很好。他们听了我的话，说，好吧，我们试试这个。让我们尝试三角测量。听起来有一个情绪问题。我们已经失去了那些对话。而这堵墙并不代表所有的精神科医生。这堵墙是心理学中被俘获的一部分。在墙下，在墙周围，在墙的裂缝里，在地下室，在后台房间，在私人诊所，在监督小组，在躯体训练，在强化训练，在本土传统中，以及大多数优秀心理学家感兴趣的所有东西中，他们实际上获得了智慧而不是获得了功绩。
There's these clinicians who can sit with a person and let what happens happen. and anticipate it, not predicted. And the traditions that understood that the body and the soul and the breath were the same conversation, those therapists were trained in modalities that the apparatus doesn't credential anymore. And if it does, it credentials them in something else that they can still do it, but they bill for it. And the researchers now finally with the technological tools to study what the body does in the room, when something genuinely changes, they're not allowed to do that because it
有这些临床医生可以与一个人坐在一起，让发生的事情发生。并预见它，而不是预测它。而那些理解身体、灵魂和呼吸是同一场对话的传统，那些治疗师受过该机构不再认证的模式的训练。如果它认证了，它会以其他方式认证它们，他们仍然可以这样做，但他们为此开账单。而研究人员现在终于有了技术工具来研究当某事真正改变时身体在房间里做什么，他们不被允许这样做，因为它
might refute the model that we have. There was this promise that eventually they were going to be able to see things that would validate what we were moving towards. We have biomarkers now. We have QEG. We have the ability to be able to see these things and understand them at the deep level. I mean, I would not have the ability to understand what I understand without our QAG brain mapping lab. What they do at peak neuroscience is amazing. But they're willing to admit that it's half art, half science. And the profession largely is not. And so the biomarkers that they've found are not allowed.
可能会反驳我们拥有的模型。曾经有一个承诺，最终他们将能够看到能够验证我们正在走向的东西的东西。我们现在有生物标志物。我们有QEG（定量脑电图）。我们有能力看到这些东西并在深层水平上理解它们。我的意思是，如果没有我们的QAG脑图实验室，我就没有能力理解我所理解的东西。他们在Peak Neuroscience所做的事情是惊人的。但他们愿意承认这是半艺术，半科学。而这个行业在很大程度上不是。所以他们发现的生物标志物是不被允许的。
And so from here, where do we go? Like, where do we go as a profession or somebody who cares about this as a possible branch of science? And not just some weird, maybe you find somebody cool, but like really, how do you quantify it? So, like, we don't know. I would like it to be a science. I'm on that side of the argument.
所以从这里，我们去哪里？就像，作为一个职业，或者作为一个关心这作为科学分支可能的人，我们去哪里？而不仅仅是一些奇怪的，也许你找到一个很酷的人，但真的，你怎么量化它？所以，我们不知道。我希望它是一门科学。我站在论点的这一边。
Some people are not. But past the 70s, when you pass, you know, 79, you have to say these things. And I don't know how to say I'm on a podcast because they bump up against too many things that are still going on right now, which is crazy because this is supposed to be this evolving thing and they're very old. I didn't know how to close the series. I didn't know how to approach this moment. even when I had people emailing me saying, we can't wait until the moment when you do and seeing how you're going to do it.
有些人不是。但在70年代之后，当你超过79年时，你必须说这些话。我不知道如何在播客上说，因为它们与现在正在发生的太多事情相冲突，这很疯狂，因为这应该是一个不断发展的东西，而它们非常古老。我不知道如何结束这个系列。我不知道如何接近这一刻。即使当我有人给我发电子邮件说，我们等不及你做的那一刻，看看你打算怎么做。
And I'm like, well, I got the notes for it, man, but I don't know how I'm going to do it. So here you go. Here's the end. You know, in 1973, Laguin, or so Laguin, who's one of my favorite authors ever, and I really wish that she had lived
我说，嗯，我有笔记，伙计，但我不知道我该怎么做。所以给你。这就是结局。你知道，在1973年，勒古恩（Le Guin），或者勒古恩，她是我最喜欢的作家之一，我真的希望她活到了
to my adulthood so that I could just speak with her because she's wonderful. She published a short story. And the story describes this city that has unbelievable happiness. And the narrator of the story keeps saying, we can't even tell you what the city is like because everyone there is so happy. And the harvest are so abundant and the streets are so clean that even if we described it accurately, which we can't, you wouldn't even believe it.
我的成年，这样我就能和她交谈，因为她太棒了。她发表了一个短篇小说。故事描述了这个拥有难以置信的幸福的城市。故事的叙述者一直说，我们甚至不能告诉你这个城市是什么样的，因为那里每个人都太幸福了。收获如此丰盛，街道如此干净，即使我们准确地描述它，我们也做不到，你甚至都不会相信。
And the art is so rich and the festivals are constant and the citizens are intelligent and inhumane. And it has no kings, it has no soldiers, it has no priests, it has no slaves, there's no It's just everything that you've ever wanted, but you didn't know how to do it, but we can't even tell you how to do it. So much of it is that description. But it has this one feature and one cost and one term. And in the contract for the city that you didn't even know you signed. But it does make the whole thing possible. So it's not even like you agree to it.
艺术如此丰富，节日不断，公民聪明且不人道。它没有国王，没有士兵，没有牧师，没有奴隶，没有……它只是你一直想要的一切，但你不知道怎么做，但我们甚至不能告诉你怎么做。其中很大一部分是那种描述。但它有一个特点，一个代价和一个条件。在那个你甚至不知道你签署的城市合同中。但它确实使整个事情成为可能。所以甚至不像你同意它。
It's just like it can't exist if you don't. There's a basement somewhere. There's this cave. And the story is called those who walk away from O'Melas. There's this cave in O'Meilas, and a small windowless room, a single child is kept in perpetual filth, darkness, and misery, and the child is fed just enough to stay alive. Because if they die, the city dies, but the child has never spoken too kindly. But that's a requirement. And the child sits in its own waist in this dim corner, and it weeps for help.
它只是像如果不是你，它就不能存在。某个地方有一个地下室。有一个洞穴。故事叫《离开奥梅拉斯的人》。奥梅拉斯有一个洞穴，在一个狭小的无窗房间里，一个孩子被关在永恒的肮脏、黑暗和痛苦中，孩子只被喂食刚好维持生命的食物。因为如果他们死了，城市就死了，但孩子从未被亲切地对待过。但这是一个要求。孩子坐在自己排泄物的昏暗角落里，为寻求帮助而哭泣。
But it has to know help will never come or else we can't have all this stuff. And every citizen of O'Mailas, when they reach a certain age, is taken to see the child, and they are told the truth. And the serenity of the city, the wisdom of its philosophers, the depth of its friendships, the tenderness of its love, the impossibility of its existence. It's all based on them seeing that, and then choosing not to see it for the rest of their life. Because everybody else walked away from O'Meelas. and they left.
但它必须知道帮助永远不会到来，否则我们就不能拥有所有这些东西。奥梅拉斯的每个公民，当他们达到一定年龄时，都会被带去见那个孩子，他们被告知真相。城市的宁静，哲学家的智慧，友谊的深度，爱的温柔，其存在的不可能性。这一切都基于他们看到那个，然后选择在余生中不再看到它。因为其他所有人都离开了奥梅拉斯。他们离开了。
And when they left, we don't know where they went. Maybe they died. Maybe they got sad and lived in a worse city. Maybe they ascended to another place. And maybe they just disappear. That once you say, I don't want to be here, you're gone. And there's so many readings of that that people might do that are like Marxist, or this is about capitalism, or this is about the engine of, you know,
当他们离开时，我们不知道他们去了哪里。也许他们死了。也许他们变得悲伤并生活在一个更糟糕的城市。也许他们升到了另一个地方。也许他们只是消失了。一旦你说，我不想待在这里，你就走了。人们可能会对它有太多的解读，比如马克思主义，或者这是关于资本主义，或者这是关于引擎，你知道，
if we have an empire, they're suffering or something. maybe and maybe that fruit is there. I'm not totally interested in that when it comes to her story because I don't think that's what she cares about at all. What I think she's saying is that there is a perfect system until you realize that system doesn't actually exist. And then you have to say, what does the future look like? And can it look different? And can it be better? And if it does, I have to walk away from this one.
如果我们有一个帝国，他们正在受苦或什么的。也许，也许那个果实就在那里。当谈到她的故事时，我并不完全感兴趣，因为我不认为那是她关心的。我认为她所说的是，有一个完美的系统，直到你意识到那个系统实际上并不存在。然后你必须说，未来是什么样的？它能看起来不同吗？它能变得更好吗？如果它确实，我必须离开这一个。
And when I do, I don't know what's coming next. And nobody can tell me. It's off the map. And I know that most people didn't do that. And if I'm in this industry right now and I know the history, which is not a ton of people, where I creep up on it in grad school, or I creep up on it as this informed patient,
当我这样做时，我不知道接下来会发生什么。没有人能告诉我。它在地图之外。我知道大多数人没有这样做。如果我现在在这个行业，我知道历史，这不是很多人，我在研究生院偶然发现它，或者我作为一个知情的病人偶然发现它，
or I creep up on it as a desperate therapist, I have to see that the establishment itself, O'Me-Mailas saw that same question numbers of times and they walked away and that's the question that faces every therapist every researcher and every patient when anyone who is not just desperate but is maybe just curious is looking at the why and the when and the how of what's happening and then has to say, but what if we went another direction? And what if we did something different? I don't know, man. Maybe it would be worse. I'm pointing out the system we have right now. I don't even have an answer for you. I'm just saying that there's this moment where you walk into the
或者我作为一个绝望的治疗师偶然发现它，我必须看到机构本身，奥梅拉斯多次看到同样的问题，他们离开了，这就是每个治疗师、每个研究人员和每个病人面临的问题，当任何不仅仅是绝望，而是也许只是好奇的人在看着正在发生的事情的原因、时间和方式，然后必须说，但如果我们走向另一个方向呢？如果我们做点不同的事情呢？我不知道，伙计。也许会更糟。我指出的是我们现在拥有的系统。我甚至没有答案给你。我只是说有这样一个时刻，你走进
basement of O'Meilus. And then you say, do I continue to know what I just knew? And the system is making you choose harder and harder between whether you look at that system and you remember your knowledge or you say, I'm going to walk away. And it used to be that there was this way that you could kind of thread the needle and weave back and forth. And then eventually you could believe that you could kind of change the system. And I believe in changing the system, which is why I am a therapist who is a network who is working inside of a society to do stuff and I'm not, you know, some weird, you know, person trying to blow the industry up. Again, my interest is still in making the system better. But it is making less and less room for you if you were doing that. And the future
奥梅拉斯的地下室。然后你说，我还要继续知道我刚才知道的事情吗？系统让你在看着那个系统并记住你的知识，或者你说，我要离开之间做出越来越艰难的选择。过去有一种方式，你可以穿针引线，来回穿梭。然后最终你可以相信你可以改变系统。我相信改变系统，这就是为什么我是一个治疗师，是一个网络，在一个社会内部工作来做事情，我不是，你知道，试图炸毁这个行业的奇怪的人。再说一次，我的兴趣仍然是让系统变得更好。但如果你这样做，它为你留下的空间越来越小。而未来
of the industry, my fear is, is going to tell you, you either have to forget everything that you ever know that you knew you have to dissociate or you got to walk away from omelus and the system will never be able to see you again but it doesn't care because you will have no effect on omelas old film flicker on a crack smoking in your father's coat dust in the beam like a cheap disco Cold machines, warm's your soft, sad, laughing notes, get carried through the tangled wires. Cold machines, warm ghosts, you sing, and something in me shakes, I'm holding on. We were not mistake. About a strike in 79, names that never made the news, I can taste.
这个行业的未来，我的恐惧是，会告诉你，你要么必须忘记你所知道的一切，你必须解离，要么你必须离开奥梅拉斯，系统将永远无法再看到你，但它不在乎，因为你对奥梅拉斯没有任何影响。旧电影在裂缝中闪烁，在你父亲的外套里抽烟，光束里的灰尘像廉价的迪斯科。冷酷的机器，温暖你柔软、悲伤、欢笑的音符，被带过纠缠的电线。冷酷的机器，温暖的鬼魂，你歌唱，我内心有什么在颤抖，我坚持着。我们没有错。关于79年的罢工，从未上过新闻的名字，我可以尝到。
on every line the rust the rain the loose and screw cold machines warm under power lines your soft machines warm you sing and something in me break some There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在每一行上，铁锈、雨水、松动的螺丝，冷酷的机器在电线下温暖，你柔软的机器温暖，你歌唱，我内心有什么在破碎。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。